We wanna take a moment to say
thank you all of you for joining
us.
Before we get into some opening
remarks our first panel we want
to be able to say thank you to
humble state for allowing us to
be here and let's give the
agents you round of applause.
I thank you so much.
We want to say thank you to all
of our panelists who have
traveled far and wide to be able
to join us today we want to say
thank you to the gentleman to my
right.
Tom west lose a chief consultant
for their joint committee on
fisheries and aquaculture round
of applause for Mr Wessel
please.
In on behalf of the joint
committee on fisheries and
aquaculture we welcome you to
our hearing on fisheries in
offshore wind development.
My name is Mike McGuire and I'm
honored to be the be the chair
of the joint committee and I
really do appreciate all of you
taking time out of your busy
schedules. To be able to be here
today we are bringing out some
additional chairs we have a full
house and we're grateful for
that.
And we welcome you to the edge
of the humble bay in those who
are watchin are streaming
broadcasts here about
California's burgeoning Pacific
after when industry.
And how it's emerging is a
critical component of our fight
against climate change.
And while this industry will be
an important source of power in
the golden state's energy
portfolio.
It's equally important I think
that we can all agree equally
important to protect the golden
state's fishery in wildlife
resources where offshore wind
turbines would be located.
Our focus today being the joint
committee on fisheries and
aquaculture is simple.
California needs to ensure this
new green energy source does not
harm our fisheries wildlife and
the local economy that depends
on a thriving natural resource.
And as you all know California
has been a leader in this nation
by establishing an ambitious a
bold goal of relying entirely on
zero emission energy for its
electricity by.
Twenty forty five governor Jerry
Brown signed a senator daily own
bill mandating the electricity
target in early September.
Two thousand eighteen he also
issued an executive order
calling for a statewide a
statewide carbon neutrality
meaning California removes is
much carbon dioxide from the
atmosphere as admits by.
Twenty forty five the Los
specific requires that 50% of
the golden state's electricity
to be powered by renewable
sources by. 202560% by twenty
thirty while calling for a bold
path forward 1100% zero carbon
electricity by.
Twenty forty five and I think
that most of us in this room.
I know I do support this
initiative and we wanted
knowledge the hard work of the
redwood coast energy authority
--
RC a has been advancing -- And
have been statewide leaders
focus on offshore wind we have
some commissioners were here
today we want to acknowledge him
and say thank you for all their
work.
And we also need to expedite the
work of the task force that was
created by the federal and state
governments to put meat on the
bone when it comes to rules and
regulations. To protect fishing
grounds and our coastal
environment where turbines would
be located.
In many cases turbines would be
place.
Where there are high winds?
Those high winds owns also
coincide with up weld waters.
These waters have high levels of
nutrients which mean there are
high levels of food sources
which means there are robust
fisheries and marine life in the
same locations were potential
turbines would be located.
We also need rules and
regulations for the large
electric connector cables
connecting the turbines with the
grade would be laid out on the
sea floor.
And address the ongoing
maintenance and operations that
would potentially impact fishing
grounds insensitive ocean
habitat.
California has to get this right
we will get this right and it's
time to involve the stake
holders on a statewide
regulatory process you're gonna
hear from the C. E. C..
As well was born that they have
launched a series of community
hearings up and down the state.
For us today we need to be a
start button that meet under the
bone.
Our number one goal of today's
hearing is to hear from all of
you Andy start formalizing the
regulatory process.
We have an all star lineup of
panelists.
And I'm so appreciative that
they all made it out here today
and we're gonna ask each of our
panelists bill to keep it within
our five minute testimony window
we have a pretty tight window
here today.
As there is another meeting
coming in this afternoon that
we're gonna have to be able to
make room.
For I would like to be able to
introduce at this time some the
dignitaries were here today and
thank them for joining us.
From this from the Humboldt
County Board of supervisors we
have supervisor fennel and
Wilson if you could please give
them a round of applause.
Thank you so much supervisors
would be.
From the arcade city council we
have councilmember Winkler here
today thank you so much as to
regret for joining us.
Representing I don't work county
ladies and gentlemen we have a
harbor commissioner here thank
you so much you commissioner
Brian stone who is here today
think as much as you stone.
From the Ferndale city council
we have councilmember or work
thank you so much for joining
us.
From the humble bay harbor
recreation district we have
Mister Coleman here today thank
you so much for joining us.
We want to take a moment to say
thank you to the hard work of
congressman Jerd half me he is
one hell of an advocate for the
north coast.
And he is lucky to be able to
have miss Imerina Mr Driskell
working on his behalf here on
the north coast we want to
welcome both of them to the
meeting today thank you so much.
Speaking of hard working
advocates we are so grateful
that his family member would has
been our partner of the 200% of
the way on this important issue.
And representing some member
what here today we have Aaron
dot and welcoming.
Also from humble bay harbor
recreation district where what
we would like to be a welcome
Mister Richard Marx to the
meeting.
In finally ladies and gentleman
representing the McKinley bill
community service district we
have Mister mail here today
thank you so much and it's for
joining us.
So everyone should receive an
agenda and I'd like to be --
Briefly go over the agenda and
then get straight into our first
panel.
Our first panel.
Made up of individual agency
representatives we're grateful
that -- We're gonna have bone
here today with the California
energy commission the California
natural resource agency as well
as the California coastal
commission represented our
agency panel focusing on all
issues of offshore wind.
Our second panel is going to be
focusing on mitigating potential
environmental impacts -- A as
well as hearing from the
industry itself we're going to
be having the we have printable
power here today we have humbled
state who will be.
Focusing on the local projects
and we have represented is an
American wind energy
association.
Coming up on our third panel we
do have environmental leaders.
From the redwood region the
Audubon society Surfrider
foundation and of course the
natural resources defense
council we'll León round out
the hearing hearing.
From humble fisheries the
fishermen in the fleet represent
will have representatives from
the Pacific coast federation of
fishermen's association the
humble fisherman's marking
association.
As well as the exact director
from responsible offshore
development alliance this is a
well rounded hearing trying to
be able to provide equal time
for a diverse set of voices and
of course.
We're gonna open up the
microphone to all of you under
public comment again thank you
for joining us and now we'd like
to be able to introduce our
first speaker here today on our
first panel.
She is the chief renewable
energy -- Pacific region --
Officer from the bureau of ocean
energy management we're very
grateful that miss sue might is
here today so Mike thank you so
much for coming up to the
hearing.
We're happy that you're here
she's gonna be providing us an
overview of the federal
perspective and then we'll go to
miss when.
Providing us with the state
perspective without further ado
let's open up our first panel
you have five minutes I'll give
you a thirty second pop welcome.
The morning if you don't like to
sit near -- Button and you were
looking for the green button
you're on good morning and thank
you senator McGuire and I'm
pleased to appear before you
today to discuss the bureau of
ocean energy management or bone
for short -- Our wind energy
planning process and our current
status so my name is nessie so
might and I am the chief of the
renewable energy section for
bonus specific region.
Covering California Oregon
Washington in Hawaii.
In recognition of the role
renewable energy can play in
independence and supporting
economic growth.
Bone has been working to advance
renewable energy to an expanded
and targeted leasing program on
both the Atlantic and Pacific
coast. To date bonus conducted a
competitive wind energy lease
sales for areas off short at
landing coast consisting of
fifteen active commercial wind
energy leases.
Off shore Delaware Maryland
Massachusetts New Jersey New
York North Carolina Rhode Island
in Virginia.
It's fully developed these
leases could generate more and
enough energy to power about six
point five million homes.
Bones in the planning stages to
identify additional potentially
serious offshore California
Hawaii New York New Jersey North
Carolina and South Carolina.
The potential demand for
offshore wind energy on the
Pacific coast has never been
greater.
With California's target of
1100% carbon free electricity
by.
Twenty forty five so pursuant to
a memorandum of understanding
with the state and establishment
of a bone California inter
governmental renewable energy
task force.
At the request of former
governor Jerry Brown.
Balm is been working with the
state of California industry and
other ocean users since October
of twenty sixteen to help to
identify areas that may be
suitable for future offshore
wind development.
Bones renewable energies leasing
strategy is founded on a process
that requires extensive planning
and analysis.
Partnerships with state
stakeholders and other
governmental agencies.
Bombs renewable energy program
occurs in four distinct phases.
We have a planning and analysis
face.
Leasing site assessment and
construction and operations.
In California we're at the early
phase of the process in the
planning and analysis face.
During this phase we seek to
identify suitable areas for wind
energy leasing consideration.
Through collaborative
consultative and analytical
process sees that engage
stakeholders tribes and state
and federal agencies.
Bom recently issued a call for
information on the nation.
On October nineteenth. Twenty
eighteen one three call areas
one on the north coast into into
central coast.
Received over one hundred
comments and fourteen companies
submitted nomination of interest
in leasing for all three call
areas.
The comments the nominations
received are now posted on a
bomb website.
So the next stage of our process
is called the identification.
Bono use the information it
received and the call to inform
my decision to offer all or part
of the call area for commercial
wind leasing.
Palmer will identify wind energy
areas.
If we determine that that there
are areas appropriate for
leasing consideration.
Palmer then initiate a formal
environmental review of these
areas under the national
environmental policy act for
potential lease issuance.
So throughout the entire process
including early planning leasing
and then review of less C.
plans.
Mon strives to engage
stakeholders who might be
impacted by potential activity
including fishermen.
Is out region interaction is
conducted through meetings
workshops soliciting
stakeholder's input into
projects citing best management
practices.
And research and monitoring
measures.
Monning partnership with the
state led by the California
energy commission and the
California ocean protection
council.
Convened a series of meetings
during twenty seventeen and
twenty eighteen during this
outrage approximately eighty
meetings were held with numerous
stake holders.
Including eighteen meetings with
fissures and fishing
organizations in crescent city.
Eureka Moro bay port Saint Louis
Santa Barbara Sacramento and San
Clemente.
Primary concerns identified by
the fishing community were.
Potential loss of fishing
grounds.
Gear entanglement mitigation
measures used by the officer
wind industry.
And loss of income.
Results of this out which are
included in the offshore wind
energy planning out reach
summary report that is also
available and bombs website.
And they were considered during
the development of the three
call area.
Going forward we will use the
feedback we receive from the
call.
And other data gathered to
compile and analyzed available
fisheries information. To
generate a special depiction of
important harvest areas off
shore in the north and central
coast.
Regions.
Data that will be included in
this analysis include fishing
vessel tracks commercial and
recreational landings.
Log book data an ethnographic
information.
Specific to potential impacts on
fishing.
At least areas identified and
awarded to a company.
Ball may include appropriate
measures to address fisheries
and wildlife concerns in the
lease instrument. For example in
the Atlantic bone has required
lessees to develop a fisheries
communications plan for use in
communicating with fisheries
stakeholders.
I'm also develops and fines and
manages scientific research to
inform assessments.
And provide a foundation for
sound science based policy
decisions that help bill manage
offshore energy in an
environmentally.
And economically responsible
manner.
That is and bone continues to
work with its partners and
stakeholders. To further refine
its initial analysis so that all
potential impacts.
Both positive and negative may
be understood.
Completed an ongoing studies
informing renewable energy
offshore California are also
posted on our website.
Thank you for the opportunity to
address the committee links to
several documents have been
related to the bone process and
the California activities have
been provided to committee
staff.
And I believe that they will be
posted on the committee's
website to provide additional
background -- As always Mambalam
is glad to provide any
additional information that the
committee may request thank you
thank you so much thank you for
your testimony we're gonna hold
questions until the end. For our
entire panel to be able to speak
we now would like to better turn
it over to miss when
representing the California
energy commission to be able to
give us a first hand look.
Of the agency whose partner in
the state agency is partnering
with the federal agency is when
the floor is yours you have five
minutes welcome.
Thank you a good morning
chairman choir thank you for
holding this hearing and
inviting me to participate.
My name is look when when I'm a
policy adviser for commissioner
Karen Douglas at the end
California energy commission.
The energy commission as
California's primary energy
policy and planning agency we
work closely with state and
federal agencies utilities and
other stakeholders to develop
and implement.
State energy policies.
California has a long history of
strong leadership an ambitious
initiative to fight climate
change and promote clean energy.
We've set high goals for
reducing greenhouse gas
emissions calling for reduction
to nineteen ninety levels by.
202040% below nineteen ninety
levels by twenty thirty an 80%
below nineteen ninety levels by.
Twenty fifty one of California's
core strategies for reducing
greenhouse gas emissions is I.
renewable portfolio standard.
Which that's targets for the
percent of energy sold to
customers that must come from
renewable energy.
The initial target was 20% by
twenty seventeen but it has
increased several times and is
now 50% by.
Twenty twenty six and 60% by.
Twenty thirty as you mentioned
earlier in addition to these
targets California also have the
goal of achieving carbon
neutrality by.
Twenty forty five so we are on
track to meet our energy and
climate goals in two thousand
sixteen we met our greenhouse
gas emission reduction goal.
For twenty twenty and renewable
energy currently serves 32% of
our energy demand.
Over the last ten or more years
the energy commission has had an
active role in planning for
different renewable energy
technologies in different parts
of the state.
Some examples of these planning
efforts that we've been involved
in are the doesn't renewable
energy conservation plan.
And the San Joaquin Valley least
conflicts fuller project.
The desert renewable energy
conservation plan as a landscape
scale planning effort.
That conserves and manages plant
and wildlife communities in the
desert regions of California
while facilitating the timely
permitting of compatible
renewable energy projects.
The San Joaquin Valley least
conflicts fuller project with
the stakeholder led process that
helps identify more than four
hundred thirty thousand acres of
land.
Most appropriate for solar
Peavey development in the San
Joaquin Valley.
And analyze the transmission
capacity available to print to
bring Peavey generation on to
the existing grad.
Both of these planning efforts
were highly collaborative and
data driven.
They emphasize public outreach
and engagement throughout this
planning processes.
It's important when looking at
complex levels of planning
efforts to coordinate with all
of the agencies who will have a
role in those efforts.
Are planning efforts have
involved is working closely with
both state and federal agencies.
In past efforts we will we've
worked closely with the bureau
of land management and the
department of defense.
And now we're working closely
with bomb on planning for
offshore wind in California.
The energy commission has taken
a lead role in coordinating the
state's participation in the
task force.
In this coordination role we
work closely with state and
local agencies such as the ocean
protection council.
The California coastal
commission the department of
fish and wildlife the California
public utilities commission and
the governor's office of
planning and research.
The task force has been active
for almost three years during
that time our priorities have
been to better understand the
potential constraints on offer
wind.
They called out Richard
engagement information and data
gathering.
And to identify research
opportunities.
As bill mentioned with our state
and federal agency partners
we've held over AT outreach
meetings and webinars.
And on the north coast alone we
held meetings in Eureka crescent
city Trinidad and blue lake with
stakeholders such as the fishing
community environmental NGOs the
native American tribes.
And the public.
Last year we also held in
integrated energy policy report
workshop in arcade it to hear
about and discuss.
The north coast regional
challenges opportunities and
solutions to meet California's
climate and clean energy goals.
The offshore wind resource along
the north coast some of the best
in the world.
Transmission is one challenge
that exist in the north coast.
However the potential call area
from north north coast in size
for local need avoiding some of
those transmission constraints.
Offshore wind has real potential
to support our climate renewable
energy goals.
Have the generation profile that
complement fuller.
It can utilize existing on shore
transmission infrastructure and
it promotes clean jobs and
investment.
Given the potential value of the
renewable resource and the parts
of the ocean and coastal
environment to Californians and
the local communities.
We believe that it is important
to continue improving our
understanding of the potential
constraints on offer wind
through our planning efforts and
continued out returning cater to
stake holders.
So thank you very much for your
time and I'm happy to answer any
questions you have for the panel
at the ends.
His mistress when very grateful
you're here these are generally
now like to turn the hearing
over to Mister potter Mister
Parker is a program manager --
In is overseen marine renewable
energy he's with the ocean
protection council so we've
heard with the C. E. C. who
works directly on all issues
with -- Bone now Mister potter
and then we're also can hear
from I doctor coverage will be
focusing on impacts potential
impacts on the ground in what
could be mitigated and or
avoided. To return the floor
over now to Mister potter
represent the ocean protection
council the floor is yours.
If I center McGuire -- In thank
you for this opportunity to
provide testimony today -- Next
slide please.
Great I'm so they'll see her the
ocean protection councils a
cabinet level state agency.
That is charged with protecting
conserving.
And maintaining California's
ocean and marine resources. For
the benefit of current and
future generations we work at
the intersection of science
policy and management in four
ways.
Taking down silos and
coordinating efforts with
partners inside and outside of
government.
Insuring best available science
informs policy and management
decisions.
Recommending actions to the
governor and the legislature to
protect ocean and coastal
ecosystems and finally finding
catalytic an innovative --
Projects to advance scientific
understanding and improving
ocean hell.
Next slide please.
Great -- So the OPC has a long
history of working on marine
renewable energy issues in two
thousand six it established a
state federal.
Marine renewable energy working
group to address the
uncertainties in the regulatory
process.
In the information needs of
agencies and stakeholders.
In December twenty eleven the
OPC adopted a resolution
specifically addressing marine
renewable energy.
Among other things the
resolution acknowledge that wave
title now sure win energy may
help California meet its long
term energy.
And carbon reduction goals
create new jobs.
Diversify the state's energy
supplies and reduce air
pollution from fossil fuel power
generation.
In addition it directs the a PC
to work with the California
energy commission on marine
renewable energy policy
development initiatives.
The OPC worked with the federal
bureau of ocean energy
management and energy commission
and watching the inter
governmental renewable energy
task force in.
Twenty sixteen under the
auspices of the task force over
the last two and half years we
help plan and conduct outreach
to the public fishermen tribes.
Vinyl groups and other
stakeholders to share
information and have discussions
around potential offshore wind
energy development on the north
and central coast.
We're planning additional north
coast out reach to fishing
communities later this year.
And early.
Twenty twenty the OPC wants to
ensure.
That marine renewable energy
projects minimize impacts to
coastal and marine environment
and the state agencies have
sufficient information to and
data to carry out their planning
and regulatory responsibilities.
Relative to marine renewable
energy development.
Consequently we're funding
studies at UC Santa Cruz UC
Berkeley humble state
university.
Then investigate the range of
potential impacts to the marine
coastal and terrestrial
environments that would result
from marine renewable energy
development.
The development of these studies
study concepts has resulted from
close consultation with state
and federal agencies research
institutions and stake holders.
Currently we're working with
very closely with the department
of fish and wildlife energy
commission coast commission.
Ball -- And humbled stay in
developing a study.
That will investigate the
potential impact of fishermen
from offshore wind development
on the north and central coast.
The PC strategic plan.
For twenty nineteen twenty
twenty four includes an
objective to minimize impacts to
the coastal marine environment.
Recreation and fishing
communities resulting from rain
renewable energy development.
Attached to the subject of our
for actions never one to
collaborate with research
institutions to develop and fund
studies and projects.
That investigate.
The environmental impacts of
deploying an operating marine
renewable energy technologies.
To collaborate with bone in the
energy commission I. priorities
and operation of the inter
governmental task force. Three
continue convening the
California marine renewable
energy working group.
And for provide information to
stakeholders on the permitting
process for marine renewable
projects through.
Workshops legislative hearings
webinars and written materials.
As the bone leasing process for
offshore wind development on the
north and central coast rolls
out over the next several years
the a BC will continue to look
for opportunities. To engage in
scientific research out reach
marine we noble and J. planning
and policy development.
Last slide.
So this is my contact
information I would encourage
folks to contact me get away I I
and to so we just discuss what's
on their mind.
I really appreciate this
opportunity to provide testimony
today they stop miss Parker
thank you so much for joining us
for grateful you're here will
have some questions -- After we
hear from Dr bridge she's a
senior environmental scientists
with California coast commission
we appreciate your presence here
today the floor is yours you
have five minutes.
Thank you very much.
I can get my presentation appear
at thank you so much for having
me today and again my name is
Kate talk a bridge I'm a senior
environmental scientists with
the California coastal
commission -- And if you could
just skip to the second slide --
And I'll just continue talking
until they show up -- So as part
most of you are probably aware
the California coastal
commission is charged with
regulating development on the
coastal zone to ensure the
protection of coastal resources
as required by the coastal act.
Now the coastal act when we're
thinking about offshore wind the
call select as a couple key
policies that will be focused on
as we review -- Offshore wind
development -- Offshore
California and those first two
policies I want to talk to I
think really aligned closely
with the goals in charge of this
committee so I wanted to
highlight those.
The first is a protection of
marine resources which include
species habitats and water
quality.
And the second is a protection
of fishing which includes both
recreational and commercial
fishing.
In addition to those policies
because like include separate
policies protecting public
access and recreation -- Minimum
minimization of impacts to
navigation and hazards --
Protection of coastal public
views and protection of tribal
and cultural resources next
slide please [inaudible]
So.
These projects are strewn
projects are incredibly complex
and they span a wide you know --
G. R. right geographic area and
go through many jurisdictions so
I created this very crude --
Diagram just to kind of walk
through it.
So.
As we've been talking about in
California were really
contemplating offshore wind
turbines out in federal waters
that's really the purview of the
federal government through bone.
Does the power from those
turbines will be connected
through cables that go through
both federal waters through
state waters and then we'll
connect on shore once they reach
on shore they'll connected to
our existing grid -- Now as part
of an overall offshore wind
project there may be components
on shore such as upgrades to our
transmission system or upgrades
at the port to facilitate
construction of wind turbines.
And that's all part of the the
picture here.
Now the coastal commission is
unique I think I think among
federal and state agencies and
that we have a regulatory role
in all of these areas.
So out in federal waters we have
federal consistency authority
and we'll be reviewing offshore
wind at two different points one
prior to the lease sale.
And one as we get further down
the line and we're looking at
projects specific proposals.
In state waters the commission
has direct permitting
authorities will we will be
providing a coastal development
permit for any cables that need
to be installed.
On shore -- Depending on where
the connection or the
developments that that is
proposed a curse the commission
either has direct permanence
already or in the case where a
local government or a port has
permanent thirty into the
coastal lacked.
Most of those projects as energy
projects are then appealable to
the coastal commission.
So because the commission will
be reviewing these projects in
their entirety in some way and I
think that's important to point
out -- Next slide please.
So what are we doing to address
--
Impacts to California's
fisheries and wildlife -- And
the first thing I sort of want
to point out there is our is our
general approach -- The goal is
to avoid impacts as much as
possible -- If they if impacts
can be avoided we want to
minimize and then fully mitigate
those impacts and I just want to
make that really clear and the
way that that's accomplished now
in the planning process is to
cite.
Lease areas and eventual
projects in locations that
accomplish those goals -- And
that's really what were we're
working on the mitigation
discussion is critical but we're
not there yet we're still
working on that try to avoid and
minimize impacts.
I will get to mitigation a
little bit further down the line
at least the specifics of what
that might look like.
So.
I'm not gonna go to too much
detail on the activities going
on because you've heard that
from the other panelists but
we're working with our state and
federal agency partners to
collect and analyze data both
existing data.
Collect new data through studies
--
We are working to develop a
thorough and transparent
regulatory process -- And then
it as but has been mentioned a
lot of time and efforts been put
into stakeholder outreach and
collaboration and that will be
ongoing.
Next slide please.
So just before I conclude I want
to focus on sort of our big next
step and commission staff is
really focused on preparing.
For a federal consistency
determination that will occur
prior to the lease sale and we
have been actively working with
bom and all the other state
federal agencies to ensure that
we have adequate information. To
conduct that review.
I want to highlight this because
I think this is the way the
store one regulatory opportunity
for the state and stakeholders
and the public to weigh in on
the leasing and citing
discussion.
That's going on within a public
hearing setting so -- We will be
looking for input from all of
you and from agencies and
anybody who would like to have
input -- Once that we go through
that phase and will be moving on
to really focusing on the
development of medication -- And
monitoring strategies as we move
forward an officer went.
So but that'll conclude thank
you.
Thank you so much for really
grateful would like to be able
Ted just ask a few questions and
we'll bring up our next panel
here.
I appreciate all of you again
for being here [inaudible]
I'm -- Talk about the ideal date
when we're gonna see these
studies back.
And how you're going to be a to
bring them together.
Can you give us a brief synopsis
about [inaudible]
What each?
At universities looking at in
where you think our focus needs
to be yeah I I can predict what
should be a little bit -- In
them mark separates here he can
talk a bit more in detail what
we're finding at humble state
but if you.
Essentially they did that the
three primary projects that
we're funding right now.
We'll have results -- Within a
year's time frame and they will
be in our own products.
That will -- That will be
delivered to the state -- In the
timing is such that that we
think will note certainly help
the cost commission for instance
with its consistency --
Determination and and with some
of the planning that will be no.
Rolling out appears well.
So are you gonna go over.
Yeah so well -- Leave the humble
state so.
Sure but okay so the the the
study that were funny at humbled
is -- You just briefly go over
that exam so everyone okay great
so basically be looking at the
the impacts to the marine
environment -- The cost on
firemen a look at some of the
the port side issues -- It also
be looking at I mean you know.
Yeah impacts in humble bay
itself perfect and they were
funny as study yet humble I'm
sorry at Berkeley that -- Looks
at the potential work force --
Ramping up in California for
after wind industry and then
we're also funding -- A great
integration analysis.
And we're still working on the
scope of of those two studies
but and we anticipate having
that.
That done probably within the
next couple weeks and then
something that that is not
related Josh sure wind is to
study at UC Santa Cruz was just
looking at the potential -- For
title energy along the
California coast.
Tile yeah -- High it's actually
broader than that it's the whole
suite a marine kinetic it's not
only title.
I'm sorry ma'am what we're gonna
have yeah I'm just waiting -- To
a Republican I know ma'am so we
have a we compromise with you if
you just want to write it down
and I will make sure we ask the
question if that's okay with
you.
And we're actually right you get
assistance with that -- In if
you don't I just read your
question and we'll get right up.
Thank you.
Which part or anything else no
that's I think that's it okay
thank you so much -- Talk to us
about.
What?
On the international -- Side
we've seen.
Several countries.
Aggressively go after offshore
wind energy.
Can you talk to us about.
Lessons learned -- In what
California should avoid -- From
other nations advancing wind
energy open the panel and I'm
gonna start with calls
commission.
So I think I have a it's
probably a better question for
either Bowman energy commission
I think they've been a little
bit more engaged on the
international front I will say.
That we look forward to you too
understanding what kind of
process sees that was set up
internationally that worked and
didn't work -- And the data they
collected and what information
did they used to make these
decisions now are optional
environment is not the same as
either the east coast or
internationally so it's not a
direct.
Link -- But it part of it is for
me at least is understanding
which process sees were put in
place like for engagement --
With different communities or
collection of environmental data
--
But I think we're still in the
process at least I am of
figuring that out and what it.
Which ones work too much
Winston.
When we go to bone anything that
we especially want to avoid --
That may not have worked that
way -- They actually thought
would in anything any model
rules and regulations that you
think -- The west should be
advancing.
I'm I thinks certainly we need
to learn from those in Europe
involvement is international
affairs office is engaged with
that the various European
countries that have developed
offshore wind and we have
agreements with them to try. To
periodically have -- Updates and
what they're doing and learn
about you know lessons learned a
lot of it primarily or though on
fixed foundations right now.
So -- You know floating
foundation is up and coming and
Wilk will begin to see that
become more majority -- And will
continue to have those dialogues
with our international partners
and to the extent that we can
bring that at the state level
and we certainly would would be
willing to do that.
But we are engaging with our
European partners to learn --
What's been done there and what
didn't work or what would work
as it would apply to California
so going forward would be
interested in.
Noble will -- Bring that down to
the state that's great.
Twenty yes though -- Offshore
wind as an advanced -- Are much
more mature industry in Europe
--
The energy commission does have
memorandums of understanding
with both Denmark and Scotland.
That we completed in a two
thousand eighteen and so we're
looking forward to working with
those countries to kind of learn
from them as to what they've
done with their projects -- As
they continue to monitor those
parties that have been sold what
they're seeing in terms of the
data.
In terms of you know I'm that
production is coming from there
--
Offer wind turbines -- You know
any other issues that they're
experiencing what they did to
get those projects completed --
Any medications they had with
fishermen and other communities
and so we've already kicked off
the initial steps to learning
from them.
We had a meeting in September --
Of last year with.
A federal agencies and Denmark
and Scott wanted I set up Bates
have a basis for learning from
them and how we could do an
information exchange.
And when you expect that to be a
coming back to this to the
energy commission into this
year.
As far as the lessons learned
that they would not repeat
except for when would that when
would you be able.
To speak to that -- So it's I
mean I don't know if there's a
certain time frame as to when
they'll get us information back
--
What I think our next step is to
meet with stakeholders in this
off shore?
When planning out for and
identify key questions that we
need to ask them -- You know and
provide those that those
questions to Denmark and
Scotland -- I think they're
willing and ready to provide us
with any information that they
can.
We just need to identify what
areas that were most concerned
with or misleading information.
Thank you please part
[inaudible]
Just.
One I think that to the the
conversation the eight from the
limited exposure I've had -- To
the European -- Into after wind
industry is the these seem to
have developed a fair amount of
technology around monitoring
which we could definitely use it
blind here [inaudible]
It's great.
There's been a lot of discussion
about timeline throughout the
state -- That we may be seen
turbines by ex date.
Phyllis in -- For California
when you think that we would
actually see.
That -- If you will.
Constructing on land and
installing offshore what is your
got -- Certainly we are in the
initial phase of the process we
have not even identified wind
energy areas let alone potential
lease areas so we still need to
environmental.
And that and then issue a lease
if all the planets line up and
we actually had a lease sale.
Mid to late twenty twenty the at
least does not guarantee or
provide authorization to
construct it simply gives the
let's see the ability to further
characterized.
And the ocean and and do some
Mike reciting and prepares
engineering report.
And when they have all of the
information on their facility
design in complete detail so
that we can do and environmental
analysis and Andy I. S. level.
And that's the only time and it
would take them a few years to
put that together -- And then
only after approval of those
plans can they begin to
construct.
So -- It's a multi year process
if you know if we had late last
season by twenty twenty eight
could be.
You know and don't quote me on
this but twenty twenty five yeah
the time frame again very rough
right yeah so it's it's a multi
year process and there's plenty
of time for engagement and you
know.
That's a lot of things have to
happen before then.
Thank you.
Talking about fisheries so I
wanna go to the doctor there so
you talked about were not even.
I'm going to paraphrase -- Were
not even at the point to start
talk about mitigation we are
focusing on avoidance.
So when it comes to avoiding
impacts when with fisheries and
especially how challenge
California fisheries have been.
Over these past four years.
What are you looking -- To to be
able to avoid those impacts.
I don't think we'll be able to
avoid all impacts to fishing I
just I think everybody in this
room understands that's not a
likely.
Outcome -- Given how broad on
the fishing resources are in
California especially here in
the north coast.
So.
The point what we're trying to
do now is gather information
which is a difficult task -- The
to give us an understanding of
where those resources are and
how we can minimize the impacts
of those this is.
It's actually quite -- Complex
process we've been working with
local fishing organizations here
in the north coast in individual
fishermen -- To develop a
process that everybody can buy
into both the agencies but and
the fishing community.
So that the results is -- Again
up process that everybody is.
Working together towards and the
product that everybody can buy
into and when I see a product
when I mean is a discussion of
what fishing resources are.
And then a discussion about how
do we cite offshore winds in
these areas so that those
impacts are minimized -- The
mitigation discussion is a
critical component of that I
don't wanna make it sound like
we're not thinking about that
because we most certainly are.
But the specifics of what that
might look like I think it's for
just that's what we're not
quite.
We haven't quite gone down that
road yet -- We're still working
with the fishing communities to
try to develop the impacts.
So.
It's weird missus might about --
Very rough -- And we are not
holder to this time Mike right
but I'm just can use an example
let's just say we're looking at
putting something in in twenty
twenty five just as an example.
I wanna make sure that folks are
leading understanding the state
side about the rules and
regulations and how that process
coincides with a hard date.
After release is been issued and
actually being able to see
someone bill something off
shore.
What do folks need to know about
the rules the regulations and
how those would be adopted and
what is that process look like
[inaudible]
Please.
I'm so I can speak to the
coastal commission process --
And and again as I mentioned on
my side we have a regulatory
role here -- Especially on the
federal portions of the project
which is the which I think is
critical -- So and that happens
it to look.
Two time frames the first is
prior to the lease sale as you
--
Heard Mr made mention -- They
are going to be doing an
environmental analysis on prior
to the lease sale will be
developing a documents -- But
before they go to the lease sale
they will submit -- A federal
consistency determination to the
coastal commission at that point
the calls commission will review
--
The least areas of the proposed
lease areas and our intent at
that point is to do sort of a
broad siding scale analysis
about what the potential
impacts.
From when development would be.
On those from those proposed
lease areas -- And as I
mentioned that's an important.
Time for everybody here to plug
into the state process -- Once
if we get past that phase as as
again we you heard there's a
process where the developers and
collect additional data develop
their projects more extensively
--
They will develop a plan and go
to them for approval of those
plans those plans also need to
come through the coastal
commission for federal
consistency review so we will be
reviewing the specifics.
Of now we would give me where
the turbines are located and
what the specific we can
actually get to the nitty gritty
of an impact analysis so that's
the other and now is there open
regulatory process in front of
the coastal commission -- So
that's another entry from from
the federal side.
There's also that initially what
on it is that a parallel effort
with the feds date that you
would be launching.
Please talk yeah so it is it is
in partnership with the federal
government it's a process that's
described in the coastal zone
management act and the coastal
commission implements that.
Law for the state of California
--
And so it's and this is how it
was done in the in the other
states that have done offshore
wind or even offshore oil and
gas so.
It's it is a well established
process will be working with the
federal government specifically
with bom. To make sure that we
get all the information we need
to do that review -- When we get
down to the project specific
phase will be working with
individual projects proponents
as well -- To get all the
details of the project so we can
review it and of course lacked
[inaudible]
It's great [inaudible]
Spot.
I would also mention that you
know there's a role of course
for the state lands commission
in the cables that would come on
shore and in you know.
In.
Leasing for those purposes.
In the state lands commission --
As the authority over bay bottom
and leases I'm so.
So how many you a state agencies
would you C. involved in the
permitting -- On at the state
level the cause commission when
I have a burning action state
lands would likely have a
permitting action -- And city of
CDW would have a would also
likely have a permitting action
and then but that's and that's
for the state waters component
there are potential on shore
components that than having even
broader array.
Of regulatory needs so for
looking at porn improvements
that brings in a whole other --
Set of local and state agencies
and federal agencies as well
that will have action so -- It's
a lot of folks that are going to
win and wait wait in on these
projects.
Thank you this went.
And while -- So some other
agencies to consider while they
won't have a permitting role in
offshore wind will have --
Regulatory or an exploratory
wellness of California and the
system operator as well the case
as well as the California public
utilities commission.
And we have included them in our
broader efforts around offshore
winds.
Thank you so much.
Any closing comments that you
all would like to be able to
make -- At this time before we
transition to our next panel or
any items that out we may have
forgotten to ask.
Hearing C..
Nine all right thank you so much
for your time we're very
grateful -- There's gonna be
some follows from this panel
that we'd like to be able when
we advance our second hearing
one of the follow ups will have
his.
Lessons learned I'm especially
on the environmental side and
fishery protection side and we'd
like to be a follow up on those
--
PC -- Studies they're being
Vance at universities and make
sure that you have the latest
information we'd like to be to
say thank you to our first panel
very much just give them around
clasp.
We're not gonna be transitioning
to our industry panel the focus
of our industry panels how
offshore wind projects can
mitigate mitigate potential
environmental impacts at C..
And we're gonna be hearing from
--
The industry we have Kevin
banister here today he's fight
vice president development for
principal power -- Representing
the home team we haven't sever
here today senior research
engineer from humble state
university at the shots energy
research center who's been front
and center on these discussions.
We also Danielle mills who's
here today she's a director with
the American wind energy
association based here in
California -- As each of those
panelists are making their way
we're gonna ask to be a switch
out the name takes thank you so
much to Carlene and to take J.
for all the work on that.
We'd like to be a welcome the
chairperson of the board of
supervisors who is here today Mr
rex bone thank you so much
supervisor bone for joining us
as well.
I. as our panelists are taking a
seat we want to say thank you to
our media services team here
from the California State Senate
thank you so much to Dana in to
fill for all their hard work.
And our surgeons who are here
today Jeremiah in the Roy.
So ladies and gentlemen we now
would like to be able to welcome
our industry panel. To the
hearing we're really grateful
that the three of you were here
we're gonna start out with
Mister Bannister he's a vice
president of Alvin it principal
power. Eight you have five
minutes Sir we welcome you to
humble county.
I will thank you at as Senate
requiring and really I honor to
be here so thanks for providing
personal power to testify -- As
said the center said my name is
Kevin banister and I'm vice
president of development for
prince will power.
I which means that I'm
responsible for the development
of our company's global pipeline
of projects -- And opportunities
but what we're working on here
in California -- Is especially
close to our hearts -- And
that's especially because we're
a California company -- And that
we've you hear humble county as
some.
A place that with investment
could become the shore side hub
for offshore wind appointments
up and down.
The west coast -- I guess more
importantly it's always a
pleasure to be here in Eureka I
mean it's a pleasure that said
this morning the fog did not
interrupt -- My travel schedule
as it has many times the past so
really happy to have gotten here
on time -- We're an offshore
wind services and technology
company that offers the floating
foundation solution to
developers.
I utilities and independent
power producers around the world
--
And while we have established
offices in Europe and are
engaged in significant
activities in Asia.
The technology itself was born
here in California where were
headquartered -- At one could
say that the technology has been
raised in Europe -- Where today
we have three projects totalling
one hundred megawatts of
capacity under construction?
Or a it our in advanced stages
of development -- These projects
will come on line in Portugal
Scotland in France in twenty
nineteen twenty twenty and
twenty twenty one respectively
--
These projects either are or
will be project financed meeting
that that commercial that
providers which tends to be very
conservative money -- Have had
their questions about technical
status in performance
satisfactorily answered.
This along with progress from
other our friends in the
industry like Ecuador -- If I.
folks have heard of Ecuador and
their high when technology which
has deployed thirty nine what
project off shore Scotland --
Demonstrates that floating wind
really has arrived as a viable
and important opportunity to
meet renewable energy goals.
Indeed there are gigawatts
thousands of megawatts of
projects dependent on floating
when foundations under planning
and development around the
world.
In California -- The
opportunities immense projects
have already been proposed for
the central north coast of the
state.
And a recent report produced by
the American jobs project
projects the Anderson could
employ over seventeen thousand
people and provide close to
twenty gig watch of capacity to
the grid.
By the twenty forties previous
reports from the national
renewable energy laboratory and
rail -- Have projected similar
numbers so it's clear that
offshore wind is a high capacity
product.
Producing energy in a way and at
times that is complementary to
the solar resource in the state
--
And that carries the potential
to generate significant new
economic activity and jobs in
humble county is one of the
areas that we believe could
benefit the most.
It's also an emission free and
environmentally friendly
resource.
And is therefore become an
important part of national
planning globally. To address
climate change but for
California to benefit from the
tremendous promise the industry
presents.
There are important
considerations that should be
addressed to proactively.
Among the most important is the
interaction between floating
offshore wind farms and the
traditional historical and
present users of the ocean
space.
In many places along the
California coast commercial
fishing is deeply significant
from both economic and cultural
perspectives.
The knowledge in honoring the
meaning for all that the free to
play is of genuine importance --
As new activity in the ocean are
proposed.
And this is why principal power
--
Guided by the partnership that
we have with the redwood coast
energy authority RCA -- Along
with the D. P. R. knack for
solutions I prioritized aground
up approach deciding our
proposed project here.
Consulting with local fishing
interests and other
stakeholders.
And ultimately signing in M. O.
U. with a humble fisheries
marketing association to ensure
that we as a project proponents
are held to account to the
principles of collaboration that
we think.
Leads to better project
development and better outcomes.
Generally.
At the site that we identified
after consultation is about
twenty five miles off shore and
just for reference.
We know that other offshore wind
developers in California feel
and act the same way castle in
for example has worked hard to
build its relationship with
fishing interest in the Morrell
bay area.
Aberration in cooperation of
this nature is paramount.
So California should continue to
engage with stakeholders
invested in the ocean space.
The state should seek to provide
developers and stakeholders with
as broad an array of options for
development as possible so that
from them.
The best part sites can be
considered and if appropriate.
Developed.
This includes continuing
dialogue with the department of
defense for example. To pursue
science based analysis around
areas that should and in some
cases should not be open to
development.
This also includes analysis and
action around the benefits that
avail from investments in port.
Or transmission infrastructure.
But because offshore wind excuse
me but because all because
waters off shore California.
Get deep quickly floating
solutions are required -- These
technologies advanced to the
Have been removed now we need to
take advantage of the sighting
flexibility floating
foundation's offer serve
California schools. To conclude
the opportunity presented
California by actually does
large so are the challenges to
maximize the industry's
potential and the benefits that
it can provide to the state and
nation.
The urgency to address these
issues is also large and we
stand ready to assess. Two is to
assist the committee in its
deliberations -- And to provide
other information very happy to
participate in a question answer
period after my testimony thank
you again for the opportunity to
testify today.
Thank you so much Mister
minister for joining us we will
hold questions until each of our
presenters were very grateful
for the here we want to say
thank you so much Mister Severi
who's a senior research engineer
at charts energy research
center.
But he really has been here on
the ground working it -- In
working with the state on all
issues -- Avoids how we can
avoid impacts to the environment
wildlife and fisheries ring turn
for over to you Sir we welcome
you have five minutes.
Thank you Sir Mike McGuire I
appreciate the opportunity to
ask by the testimony today -- So
I believe I have a presentation
all just let that come up --
After one complaint important
part in California's clean
energy future and can help meet
this help the state meet its
target of a 100% clean renewable
energy.
By.
Twenty forty five Bob Sherman
resource in California and in
particular on the north coast is
one of the best in the
continental US.
With average wind speeds
exceeding ten meters per second
in some locations.
California's north north coast
has a strong opportunity proffer
when development.
Because of the support Sir
Superbowl when resource.
Existing deepwater port
infrastructure in Humboldt Bay
and limited overlap with US
military operations.
However there are several
challenges to development.
These include electric
transmission constraints part of
the structure requirements.
Stapler concerns environmental
impacts.
And geological or geologic or
seismic issues in your
powerpoint is up and running
where.
Thank just like find print okay
perfect -- Besides energy
research center at Humboldt
state university is working on
feasibility analysis to quantify
the opportunities for energy and
economic development.
And also understand the
challenges impacts and
constraints of officer one
development on the north coast.
Next slide please.
At the start center we're
working on three projects one of
which is been funded and the
other two have been proposed and
are pending funds.
The products -- Over one your
time line -- Beginning this
spring.
Results and outcomes will be
disseminated by winter and
spring of twenty twenty I'll
briefly describe the scope and
status of each of the three
project proposals.
The first project looks at the
when resource generation profile
and transmission constraints
this project has been proposed
to the bureau of ocean energy
management.
As pending funding the product
will look at the following tasks
first.
The resource assessment will be
used to evaluate the wind speed
resource and calculate the
potential energy generation
profile from different wind farm
scales locations on the north
coast.
Second we'll be looking at the
great compatibility which will
evaluate the like trickle
transmission capacity to connect
offshore wind into the regional
grad.
Transmission capacity is very
limited and I'm all county and
significant upgrades will likely
be required props or when
development this task will
partner with.
Pacific gas -- An electric our
local utility to run a power
flow transmission model and
estimate the required
infrastructure upgrade classic
costs. For different one farm
scales.
Next this project will be
looking at the ad -- Subsea
cable. To determine the options
and feasibility first I've C.
cable to transmit power from
let's centers -- From from wind
farms and on the north coast to
Los centers in the San Francisco
Bay Area -- Lastly we'll.
Conduct an economic analysis to
develop a bottom up cost model
to calculate the cost for
offshore wind energy for
different development skills in
this region.
Next there is a project that
evaluates the concerns
surrounding offshore wind
development this is a multi
disciplinary project has been
awarded and funded through.
The California ocean protection
council.
This project includes four task
as described their ingrained.
First the environmental impact
task.
This will analyze the likely and
potential environmental impacts
to birds marine mammals fish.
Ben thank armor organisms and
other relevant species we're
working with ecological
consultants HD Harbin associates
to complete this analysis.
Second will be looking at
coastal infrastructure this task
will assess current conditions
of coastal infrastructure
including the port and harbour
and described anticipated
upgrades Wilk required. To serve
an offshore wind industry Mike
McDonald an engineering
consulting firm with expertise
not for one important event
development will be assisting
with this work.
Next we'll be looking at
stakeholder engagement to
identify stakeholder benefits
and concerns and termin
approaches to address these.
Issues stakeholders including
commercial and recreational
fishing community environmental
organizations developers
regulators labor unions and
others.
Lastly this project will include
a policy analysis to evaluate
environmental permitting
processes.
And energy policy related to
offshore wind at local state and
federal levels.
This portion of the work of a
strong focus and energy polity
in energy policy. To understand
the complex pathway and time
lines and a great officer went
to St electricity markets.
Lastly the third project looks
it looks at some additional
considerations props or when
development.
This product has been proposed
to the California governor's
office of planning and research.
And is pending funding.
The product is looking at three
men issues first military
mission compatibility this task
will investigate how development
officer went on the north coast
can be done in a way that is
compatible compatible.
With military operations in
northern California.
Next.
There was -- Task looking at the
geologic and seismic concerns.
The staff will assess the
geological seismic issues
associated with C. four anchors
anchoring and in particular bill
also look at the issues with
horizontal directional drilling
for cable and fall into the bay.
Lastly there will be -- Subsea
cable environmental analysis
which will conduct a preliminary
environment out of my mental
analysis of a sub C.
transmission line including
impacts of benthic organisms and
other marine life and go
systems.
Next slide please.
Where the beginning of a
feasibility analyses rocks or
wind in the short time available
today I'm able to describe our
our work at at at a high level
but I'm not able to go into that
much detail?
You're welcome to ask any
questions about any piece this
now sister followed by email.
With more information our
contact information shown here.
For me and then also for the
principal investigator Arne
Jacobsen.
Arnie is the director of the
shot that is a research center
and he was on fortune and able
to be here because he's
traveling internationally for
other work.
You can look at our centers
website for more information and
for interim per reports and
deliverables that will be
published there when they're
complete.
Thank you again center McGuire
for your time here today and I
appreciate the opportunity to
find this testimony thank you so
much we're very grateful Sir in
will be essence of questions
you're just a bit.
We are appreciative that Daniel
mills is here she's with
American wind energy association
based here in California we
welcome you miss mills a
committee you have five minutes
to floors horse.
Thank you senator exposure to be
here today and really appreciate
you welcoming us to this
beautiful community on this
lovely day yeah -- I'm Daniel
mills with the American wind
energy association of California
a ouija is the US trade
association that represents the
wind industry -- And our member
companies are global leaders in
utility scale wind energy
technologies were interested in
delivering the benefits of
utility scale wins both onshore.
And offshore to Californians --
American when power was born in
California roughly around the
same years me -- And after wind
energy is the future -- We I.
Californian our member companies
are applying the lessons that we
learned from our experiences
with lance bass wind -- As well
as our experiences on the east
coast with offshore winds. To
the California market to make
sure that California after wind
starts off on the right foot --
And in a manner that maximizes
the value that it brings to
California.
At one of those lessons is that
it's really critical to
collaborate early with
environmental and other
stakeholders -- And often
throughout the process of
development -- And it's clear
that officer wind energy is
coming to California companies
are hiring and watching the
market for signals of stability
and opportunities for growth.
That opportunity is enormous --
Kevin mentioned the the job
study that -- Explained that
over seventeen thousand jobs
could come to California -- If
we maximize the potential
opportunity and see about
eighteen gigawatts of
development off the coast that's
an enormous number and if we're
going to get to a significant --
Market like that we need to make
sure that every step of the way
we're checking in with critical
stakeholders we'll be
interacting with these projects
on a day to day basis -- So we
have to start with the best
projects in the best places and
make sure that we get it right
with our eyes and scaling up.
After wind has potential to
revitalize port communities like
Eureka -- And to bring
manufacturing to the stake state
and California is very well
positioned to tap into that
potential -- Given the 1100%
clean energy policies that we
have -- And our carbon neutral
goal.
On the east coast after wind
continues to advance advance --
Improving economies and through
robust strict state policies
that have recently been signed
into law by a bipartisan group
of governors so.
Leaders in Massachusetts Rhode
Island Connecticut New York New
Jersey and Maryland have all
made and Virginia also have all
made very substantial offshore
wind commitments.
And we expect offshore wind to
continue to mirror they M. Costa
claims that we've seen with land
based went throughout the
country.
We know that after winds can
complement California's
generation and low profile so
Kevin also mentions a as did
look plan I believe the the
complementary nature between
wind and solar in the state so
as we move. To higher
penetrations of renewable energy
--
We know that the seller is very
predictable it comes off line
around. Six o'clock PM roughly
when the sun is setting that is
exactly the time where offshore
wind resources are ramping up
and started to pull the hardest.
Those resources can continue to
blow throughout the throughout
the evening and through the
night which can help us charge
our electric vehicle fleets
California also has very.
Aggressive -- Electrification
targets and can also help with
night time heating loads in the
building and industry sector.
So there's enormous pop
opportunity for D. carbonization
her as well -- We also know the
officer wind can have a capacity
factor between sixty and 70%
based on what we've seen in
European markets.
Roughly what that means is that
you see -- Just as a sense of
scale coal and natural gas have
capacity factors of 5455% --
Throughout the US so essentially
officer wind will be generating
more of the time and some of
those conventional resources it
can have enormous D.
carbonization benefits -- And we
know that it's also -- It's also
I'm going to bring those jobs to
the state as well.
But in order to get there we
know that collaboration is going
to be key so I'm gonna talk
about three different areas
where.
We is collaborating and
individual companies as well --
To make sure that we're doing
this responsibly.
The officer winds industry we
know and through the work that
we've done with the department
of defense can enhance national
security.
And is compatible with military
operations and readiness -- We
know that adding energy a
pendant independence in an
office or a home grown energy
source like off her wins.
Can help reduce our reliance on
foreign energy sources and
enhance our national security --
And and we've seen this
undulating bayside -- We're
ready to work with the
department of defense we're
doing so in Washington DC
include as well as the Coast
Guard and the navy -- We're
finding workable project citing
locations -- We also know that
we can co exist with the
commercial and recreational
fishing industries and diverse
--
Diversify and strength in the U.
S. maritime economy we're seeing
that through individual company
efforts like what Kevin
mentioned -- And engaging as
well and some of the ongoing
studies that are happening.
With the offshore projects on
the east coast like block island
[inaudible] Thirty second.
And we've also learned a great
deal from our work with the
environmental groups who within
we partner on the American wind
and wildlife institute -- This
is a partnership of industry
leaders agencies and
conservation groups that work
together to insure and
facilitate the timely
development renewable energy.
Excuse me at develop -- Projects
responsibly without affecting
wildlife with habitat.
Excuse my voice -- So in
conclusion -- We're really
grateful for this I think we
have seen that California is
already following best practices
by having this meeting relief
there no projects online we have
a really great chance to get
this right.
And we look forward to working
with you in the future.
Thank you so much miss bills
were very grateful into our
panel I would like to be a sort
of a some questions -- First of
all I would like to be able to
go -- To the shots energy center
for so [inaudible]
Talk about.
In your beliefs so there's been
some discussion about ten when
--
Turbines off of the humble
coaxed.
So what type of upgrades you see
may be needed if you can just
walk us through that.
In how many megawatts would that
be is at a hundred make watch
just just give us a an overview
if you don't mind -- Yes so if
there were ten megawatts of a
typical sized -- People are
looking at is maybe ten to
twelve megawatts per turbine so
that would be around a hundred
two hundred twenty megawatts for
for that particular farm -- As
Daniel mention with a sixty or
70% capacity factor they'll be
producing out most -- We'll need
to get the details about how
much energy the precinct I
guess.
Will be required in several
places not only the port but
also in particular transmission
upgrades I don't believe that
humble county is great has the
capacity to absorb.
A hundred or even fifty
additional megawatts of
electricity -- Right now so
significant upgrades will be
required either in that overland
transmission lines going east to
the to the interstate five
corridor or potentially going
south.
Along existing utility right
away as so will be significant
electricity transmission
upgrades but then also
significant part development
will be required both -- To due
the assembly but also on going
on operations and maintenance of
the of the Germans.
So since every or an expansion
so have how has that price break
down.
Or in the investment break down
--
Happened in other regions so can
you give us -- In rural areas
whether it's on the east coast
or internationally -- That we
need to be able to increase the
capacity for transmission.
How was that -- Investment
breakdown taken hold.
Who pays for it?
What's a good question -- And
certainly it's it's relevant to
offer when developing in
California -- All right.
As well as I'd certainly implied
anyway in the and by the
previous panel -- It is done
differently in different places
and where we've seen offshore
wind take hold.
Sort of first -- Really in
northern Europe so maybe and you
know Denmark and the Netherlands
and even in the U. K. Germany.
In these places generally what's
happened is that at the central
government has -- Has actually
provided access to transition to
the project developer and that's
the and it's incorporated it's
not a part of what that what
they what the what the developer
including the cost that the
consumer sees for those projects
so it's something that.
Obviously it's seen either
through taxes or through through
a like a feed in tariff type
arrangement but so the developer
it's taken care of by by
somebody else.
So transmission or denies or for
example sure signs can
paraphrase here so let's just
say we're gonna have -- Ten off
the humble cooks -- Again just
I. prophetical ten off the the
coast hundred hundred twenty
make a whites.
It may be in the hundreds of
millions of dollars to be able
to create it to be able to
expand.
The capacity for those
transmission lines in some areas
in northern Europe.
The the government has paid for
the upgrade of transmission
lines while the private industry
--
Contractor has installed the
turbine turbines and the cantor
cables is that accurate.
I'm oversimplifying yeah yeah.
You know I think from our
perspective we think that sent
for the project here and humbled
we think that -- There may be
some ways that we can avoid the
major upgrades -- That would
result in a you know in addition
to hundreds of millions of
dollars of costs for an initial
project -- I think you fear
summarize that situation well
though yeah do you want to talk
about those about some ways to
be able to mitigate that the
cost C. if you don't mind --
Well for I I'm not really
qualified to talk about sort of
the transmission sort of wrap
around that we might be able to
achieve here and I. in humble
county transmission as you may
know is it.
Like an almost impossibly
complex -- Area -- Seven that's
that that's that's just tough
one for me I'm gonna add that as
a follow up okay so will -- Talk
about [inaudible]
Lessons learned.
Internationally.
So we're asking the last panel
about lessons learned especially
when it comes to fisheries and
the environment.
So what we what measures have
been deployed by both private
industry as well as government
to be able -- To have compatible
uses.
Allow the fleet to continue to
operate as well as have the
renewable energy can either
three of you talk about that
all.
Not all at once.
I don't have the I don't have
the global perspective from
Europe I think -- California has
had a lot of experiences the
previous panel explained with --
You know making sure that we're
minimizing impacts for a variety
of different technologies and
been doing it for hydro power
for a long time so there are a
lot of different lessons that we
can use.
And apply from other
technologies as well that is
other parts of the country but I
don't have the information on
environmental issues globally.
Thank you can follow
[inaudible]
Please -- I I also have more of
a a local focus here but I think
I'd say that one thing -- That
that could be a lesson learned
from the east coast is states
setting -- Targets for offshore
wind development helps give the
industry both a vision of how
they're moving forward but also
give the state some ability to
plan ahead a probe really ball
for transmission but also for
environmental concerns.
The environmental studies.
The enviro study that you're
dancing now shots [inaudible]
How?
How will be able to overlap for
example the central coast or is
it?
More just focus on the north
coast fill us in on that.
This will also be very focused
on the north coast we're gonna
be looking specifically at two
separate areas one of those is
the bomb call area and one of
them is further south of Cape
Mendocino that I was really
super wind speeds.
Within that area and and just
around that we're gonna be
looking at population seasonal
patterns of migration what type
of birds fish marine mammals are
there and these are gonna be
very specific to the region and
the unique -- Ecosystems we have
up here so I think maybe some of
the results and methods maybe
transferable to different
regions but I think it to be
very focused on understanding
one of the potential impacts.
The other two cities have yet to
be funded let's just say you
kick off tomorrow are you today
talking twelve twenty four
months how long would it take
you D. thing to be a complete.
These are all twelve month
projects -- We're hoping and
expecting that -- The other two
will be beginning within a month
or two and we still expect -- Be
heading deadline so five next
spring or for results yeah
reports in would you describe
the studies as initial -- Or you
will you need to be able to go
back to be to do further review
after what you find from this
these studies that you're
launching now.
I think different tasks have
will have different levels of
detail so for example when we're
looking at a subsea cable for
long distance transmission
that's gonna be a very high
level because it's a preliminary
thing nothing similar it's been
done on the west coast.
But other aspects of the study
such as the transmission.
Integration will be will be
detailed and be pretty -- Final.
What was that hi aspect about?
Would like to be to just talk
about -- The floating turbines
can you just.
Give us thirty thousand foot
view of what the time line for
construction is off shore -- In
what that would look like this
so that we have a a visual
leaving here today -- I don't
know if.
Every Mister Bannister yeah sure
it M. and an old also just give
a quick description of what our
technology looks like just just
to help people visualize so
basically -- Our technology
recalled the wind flowed there
are three columns that and if
you look at it from above
effectively form any collateral
triangle -- I just circular
columns -- Upon one of those
columns we have fixed the wind
turbine and the ideas that we
fix the wind turbine in a
protected environment.
Of the harbor and then we tow
out that fully assembled unit to
the project site and at the
project site we would have pre
deployed -- The mooring and
what's called the export cable
so the cable that actually
brings the power to shore.
I saw the operation is what
happens all at shore with the
exception of the toe out.
And then the connection of the
mooring lines of the cables so
each of these systems will have
one morning line that extends
off of each of the column so
total of three mooring lines --
For each wind turbine -- The
foundation itself -- Our team
has a from sometime ago has
history in oil and gas -- That
the foundation is called a semi
submersible that's that's sort
of the type of foundation it is.
This type of foundation I'm has
been deployed in places like the
Gulf of Mexico and in the North
Sea for decades and decades so
there's a lot of experience with
this type of foundation.
What we're talking about is much
much smaller than this sort of
the Gulf of Mexico you know
enormous like oil?
Type of type of systems -- So
the construction window -- Can
be fairly compressed -- Because
we're not reliance on heavy lift
operations offshore like you
would see -- For what we would
call a conventional or bottom
fixed offshore wind project
where.
You know you have a foundation
you pile it into the C. bad and
then you bring out the whole you
know that on a on a vessel you
bring out.
The tower than a cell the blades
then you have to lift that all
the way up to what's called the
hub height which may be.
You know three hundred three
hundred fifty feet above the sea
surface we do all that work at
shore so the offshore works.
Are much much simpler with
flooding systems like ours so it
hundred megawatt projects.
That's you know it is confined
to some to the to open whether
windows we it's difficult can be
difficult to be out there in
January doing this type of work
--
But in the you know scholars
from April through October --
Depending on the consultations
that we have with especially the
environmental at stake holders
and also fishing interests what
times are open for those types
of activities.
It would take two seasons I
would imagine -- So you know
maybe one summer then another
summer to deploy the full. One
hundred megawatts -- I think you
as the industry matures here in
California that will be
compressed further as we all you
know we learn from learn by
doing and get better at it.
Got it in you talked about jobs
talk with us about permanent
jobs one time our temper if you
will in the construction phase
so.
Go through that if you if you
don't mind Spencer -- Certainly
there construction phase jobs
and then there's I went M. at
jobs -- Which are for you know
for the life of the project and
I think one of the things that
is quite compelling we're seeing
it now in the on shore -- Wind
world where a lot of that the
turbines and towers that are you
know placed on shore now being
recommissioned in repowered.
And with floating -- Foundation
technologies like ours that
opportunity exists to do the
same so maybe a project has a
twenty or twenty five your life.
You can tell the foundation back
to shore.
Replace the turbine the turbine
in this case is the sensitive
piece of equipment that has
shorter life.
Then the foundation itself so
there is there is the
opportunity not to for that for
that sort of one time work of of
construction the ongoing work of
operation and maintenance and
then there will be
opportunities.
For we think for re powering --
Existing projects but we also
see that the opportunity in
California so large when we're
talking about twenty gigawatts.
By the twenty forties twenty
forties is only twenty you know
twenty something years from now
--
That is that that's a lot of
work to be done.
So they may be one time jobs ask
for a particular project but we
do use to see the potential --
For projects to be developed in
ultimately constructed in
parallel.
Thank you so much miss mills.
We have seen this on León bay
side as well there right now
thirteen manufacturing
facilities in California that
support.
Land based wind -- And wind
turbine technician training
programs within the state that
--
You know that go out and service
turbines throughout the country
--
So if we see you know a robust
wind resource in New Mexico or
Wyoming they can go there you
can do the same thing with
offshore winds -- There's also
you know I think this is why --
Keeping our eyes on a a larger
target is really helpful because
that's what will actually bring
the supply chain into California
earlier in the process so that
we can get some of these parts.
Manufactured in California and
then you know if we get to a
point where there's additional
development throughout the
Pacific be exporting some of
those parts -- Throughout.
The world.
Thank you so much would like to
be to see if there's any closing
comments and I like to be added
to our follow ups as well
including comments for either
the three of you will start with
miss mills and work our way to
the left.
Since no I just I encourage you
to continue to lean on us as a
resource and we'd like to
interact with a lot of the
important stake holders who are
here today and moving forward to
make sure that we do this right.
Thank you thank you so much
suffering.
I look for the opportunity to
present some of our result after
we've gotten into the studies
will but further every great you
have as four think so much
Spanish.
I would just say that there are
several lessons that we are
bringing from Europe -- Some of
them are you kind of down in the
details you know at the things
about cable protection systems
that -- That will make the
cables last one which means that
you have to deploy them less
frequently.
I would say the floating
foundations themselves in some
ways our lesson learned from
Europe -- We C. significantly
reduced risk -- And in fact so
significantly reduced
environmental impact when using
floating foundation so we
deploy.
Pretty conventional offshore
anchors that are entirely
removable as opposed to doing
piling into the C. bad which not
entirely but is a very pretty
pretty common practice.
For the bottom six foundations
and we know that.
Those you know that since severe
sort of acoustic signature that
comes with that piling is really
detrimental for marine mammals
in particular so with floating
foundations there's there's you
know less impact in the
deployment and installation
phase.
And then perhaps the greatest
benefit there's been a lot of
discussion about where we are in
this part in this practice now
is avoidance you know trying to
avoid harm.
Flown foundations give you
greater opportunity to do that
because you can't.
You're not dependent so much on
what the C. bad conditions are
or how deep the water is you can
go to the place where first
maybe where the wind is good.
But also maybe the first place
that you go is where you know
the a variety of stakeholders
say this is where we think you
should go in the wind resources
sufficient to enable an economic
projects so it provides.
A tremendous amount of
flexibility that that's really
valuable.
Andy so much really appreciate
your time if you can please give
a round of applause for industry
panel thank.
As we move forward in our Jim
that we want to say thank you to
all of you for hanging with us
we're gonna be moving into the
environmental perspective.
Our next panel is title
protecting our ocean environment
in balancing the need for green
energy perspectives from
environmental leaders we are
grateful that we're gonna have
to check -- Can here today he's
--
With the redwood region Audubon
society Jennifer savage she is a
proud humble resident and she's
now the PO California policy
manager for the Surfrider
foundation.
And we have seen deals worth
your to date with the natural
resources defense council.
Ladies and gentleman.
We're grateful for all of their
work.
We are going to then hear from
the fleet -- In giving us their
perspective from California's
fishermen we're gonna have
checked here to the left then
Jennifer and insane D.
[inaudible]
All right.
I got a plays Janet thank you so
much for joining us were really
grateful that the three of you
are here.
Hi thank you for your hard work
each of you have five minutes
I'll give you a thirty second
prompted for getting close we're
gonna step is start with Mr
Hogan who is with the Audubon
society welcome Sir in providing
the environmental perspective.
Thank you Mister McGuire -- I'm
glad to be here thank you for
everyone for attending.
Tom.
All right about chapter along
with California Audubon.
Is committed to sustainable not
hard to carbon energy sources
when being one sold beer not
being another.
Hi to power partial power has
its -- The dams and salmon
migration and pollute water
pollution.
So we're not not considering
that all.
Our Richard beach reason Audubon
chapter our purpose.
We advocate for protection of
birds and wildlife by supporting
conservation efforts to protect
wildlife and their habitats.
Our mission is to promote a wise
balance and responsible and
ethical use of natural
ecosystems on our local national
and global scale.
And protect the biotic and
abiotic components of local
national.
And global natural systems --
Scope of our chapter covers all
of bill nor Kumble county.
And adjacent areas of Siskiyou
county of medicine -- County and
western Trinity county --
Personally I graduated from
mobile C. numbers in nineteen
seventy with a degree in
biology.
And after graduation went to
work for the for service in
southern California -- Working
in fire control and then and
prescribed burning research --
With the experiment station down
in Glendora -- After a four year
stint with the US army at the
Walter Reed army institute of
research in Washington DC.
I returned back up normal state
university because is a good
place to raise a to this area to
raise a family where I I began
working for read the sciences
lab on there -- Actually first
on a silviculture project which
got disbanded.
And then -- Millie picked up by
a wildlife project -- In
nineteen eighty three and ever
since nineteen eighty three
until my retirement.
Two thousand eleven I worked as
a as a wildlife biologist --
I've been involved with them
with the Audubon since --
Nineteen nineteen eighty seven
in nineteen ninety eight a
spirited effort. To get Hubble
they complex.
Included in the western hills
for shore bird reserve network.
And that was as a intern as a
almost as an international site.
And that was just recently
upgrade this year. To a
hemispheric side -- Very little
is known about the bird
component do we have off shore
out here -- Its it's too far out
for regular studies -- Doctor
stand Harris -- One thousand or
follow G. instructor emeritus
mumble sting overstate.
Has compiled notes going back --
To nineteen forties and through
his stern studies and research
both sort of gone off shore have
compiled some information on the
US pieces we have offshore --
There are at least forty species
that utilize the offshore waters
off of California -- And I want
--
To I want to highlight a couple
of local let me first start
Maria -- Including that now was
a floating platform your
increase in in.
Causing a marine ecology area
you're you're you're creating a
platform with two which allergy
will attach -- You'll get
invertebrates then are
collecting around those -- The
LG and fish moving it around
those -- Around those two so
you're you're creating a a micro
environment -- And I'm sure the
fisheries people will be
addressing that further -- We
have a number of pelagic species
it -- Such as albatross is.
Sure waters petrels -- Cruise
the waters off shore.
The strong westerlies we have --
Pick up close because new
channel willing along the coast
that new trend up willing brings
a lot of there's a lot of new
trenches. To the area --
Providing a lot of food for
Bates -- Big fish and then you
see these.
Long winged narrow long wings --
Oceanic birds.
Cruising those water there they
are getting left from wind
shear.
Off of the water soon most of
the time they're going to be.
Broadly just soaring -- Looking
for looking for opportunities
but so you figure that once you
get to an area where you have --
An offshore structure could be
an oil well it could be a piece
of of flotsam -- Where you have
organisms attached to it
creating a small environment --
Gonna get small fish with that
and the and potentially -- Balls
of bait fish.
In which these sure waters -- Or
not just cruising flap over a
water maybe -- Three meters ten
feet high but or circling and
soaring high. To spot these big
fishing and diving down -- To to
get there early to get our food.
Thirty seconds okay -- When I go
to a to the US slides in please?
What a particular you
particularly of dress black
Brant -- Along the coast here --
Black -- Humble they were the
seal grass is very important to
to the block. To the Pacific
black Brant -- Yeah is they
futility they feed on the rest
of the band they migrate between
Alaska peninsula.
And Baja California networks are
way up the coast. To humble pan
further on north of to the Puget
Sound.
And then -- My great -- Mike a
from future sound up to the
Alaska peninsula.
And even up -- To up to champ
Kamchatka peninsula.
You see out.
That they're bringing up in the
office -- Yours was.
In the arctic -- Concern about
the black rat population is it's
a lot of not a lot is known
about.
Some of their water ecology and
so on the we have about a
hundred and fifty thousand black
Brant Pacific brand in this area
here -- And that's about
222-006-2000 that's about to
limit -- Counting those each
year up in Alaska peninsula
before they migrate south. To
allow -- A hunting limit each
year based on those numbers --
M. sorry we're gonna have Ted
okay great policies would you
you have any concluding remarks
please.
Now thank you no no thank you so
much so going to mobile.
We took questions will come back
with questions on that specific
migratory patterns in just a bit
okay thank you so much for your
presentation.
We are grateful that Jennifer
savages here she's represent the
Surfrider foundation -- In is
the California policy manager
for the foundation.
The floor is yours ma'am.
Thank you and good afternoon
it's really great to be home and
to see so many familiar faces.
I Mike from I thank you and I
was instructed so well Hey
there.
Good your J..
I was saying it's great to be
home it's great to see so many
familiar faces and thank you
senator McGuire for holding this
forum.
And and thank you to the other
panelists today it's been really
informative so far.
In addition to working as
Surfrider foundation California
policy manager and I'm also a
twenty one year resident of
humble county has been seventeen
of these years.
Living in Manila along Humboldt
Bay.
I'm extremely familiar with the
challenges and the benefits of
living on the north coast and
the pride that we take in our
connection to the natural world.
I also served on the north coast
regional stakeholder group
during the marine life
protection act implementation
process which proved to be a
valuable opportunity and
privilege really to learn more
about our ocean wildlife the
concerns of our local fishermen.
The complexity of balancing
multiple interest. To that end
Surfrider NRDC Sierra Club
national Audubon society and
defenders of wildlife are among
the many NGOs that have been
tracking and commenting on
California's offshore wind
energy process as it's been
moving along.
First and foremost Surfrider
foundation always tries to
support renewable low impact
sources of energy of course I
mean that's a no brainer.
Breaking free of fossil fuels is
a global imperative it's truly
the greatest imperative of our
time California's commitment to
renewable energy is both
necessary and admirable.
But Bob annual energy is
obviously the right thing we
still have to do the right
things the right way.
And that's what the concerns
about officer wind energy can
men well we supported in concept
we remain keenly aware.
That as related to our waters
the technology is still largely
unproven untested launching a
project offshore in an area
critical to marine life must be
done without most Karen
preparation.
M. as discuss briefly the M.
offshore wind farms can harm
birds and number of different
ways.
Electromagnetic fields
underwater noises and vibrations
can affect orientation and
navigational ability.
Of our marine mammals one your
wind turbine generators produce
less sound than older turbines
impact of low frequency sound on
whales dolphins and other ocean
creatures still need to be
investigated.
Under water support pilings
anchoring devices scour
protection materials and
electromagnetic fields could
cross cause an increase or
decrease invent the community's
ultranationalist vitamins.
And possibly a at migration
patterns.
Loading hit a power cables can
lead to entanglement of whales
and other marine mammals and
there's there's other concerns
as well that sandy will be
speaking greater details about
those and other threats.
So I will move on to say.
That despite the admirable
quantity of meetings that bone
in the C. C. have held what
we're hearing from community
members is the need for improved
quality of meetings.
Clearly opportunities exist for
a more inclusive and transparent
process that would ensure site
selection reflects environmental
and other concerns.
Surfrider in our colleague
organizations have consistently
advocated for a scientifically
and stakeholder driven citing
process that prioritizes.
Environmental sensitivities.
Specifically we've asked the
state to help secure funding for
third party scientific analysis
of the data in the database and
and the creation of an
environmental sensitivity layer.
Anteon cyst on a process that
such high environmental bar for
this new technology in the ocean
that is so vital to our economy
and our well being.
So we were heartened when last
November at because the
commission meeting
representatives of the coastal
commission energy commission a
state lands commission.
Adamantly supported these ask
but nearly six months later
there's been no follow up.
Even today we've heard the
phrase looking forward to in
regards to figuring out
virtually every single detail
that needs to happen between now
and the actual deployment of the
turbines.
If we should get so far which is
fine and it's appropriate.
But it also suggests that
building a wind farm out at sea
has a lot of challenges yet to
be solved.
So well we want to increase the
promise of offshore wind
enthusiastically we definitely
need much more information to
show that the potential benefits
can actually manifest at all.
And can do so without harming
the birds fish and marine
mammals already facing threats.
Thank you so much miss savage as
a follow up questions here in
just a bit.
We're not gonna turn over to
miss it was worth it
representing the natural
resources defense council.
Says with your five minutes the
foreshores thank you.
At first like Ted just express
my regret that I have to follow
John savage.
Again I'm sandy Ellsworth with
the natural resources defense
council and I'm with the energy
C. oceans program.
I want to thank senator McGuire
for hosting.
This forum and hearing and also
for so whole heartedly embracing
the idea right off the bat that.
In order to develop offshore
wind we need to do it in a way
that protects the marine
environment and factors and
other stakeholder uses.
California is a leader in
climate change mitigation and
marine protections self let's
guide with these two principles
elevating them both equally we
can do at I also just wanted to
share that this is the first
time I've been -- So far north
in California and it was
immediately clear driving in
yesterday just how special
humble bay is.
An RTC fully.
Recognizes that addressing
climate change through dramatic
D. carbonization is urgently
needed.
As such we are of course.
Supportive of responsibly cited
offshore wind we've been very
active in the Atlantic in
promoting at and working with
developers to ensure that the
highest degree of marine
protections are upheld.
Today I'm going to discuss some
of the environmental
considerations building on chat
and Jen's remarks -- Some of the
environmental considerations the
Saudis associated with floating
offshore wind and I'd also like
to highlight some of the science
needs.
And research priorities that
energy C. and other
organizations have identified.
Can I have the next slide please
[inaudible]
Great.
I briefly highlight some
environmental considerations
associated with floating
offshore wind turbine so
hopefully these two images are
somewhat instructive.
There's concern about habitat
loss there's no denying that
these turbines will have some
sort of benthic foot print they
have to attach to the C..
For so where they're placed is
very important.
They also penetrate all of the
water column with very long
cables because they use
incurring systems.
Which is about a fat in some
regards.
But there is plenty of potential
for in all of water interaction
with the many cables.
There's also concern about
secondary entanglement we're
very clear on the fact that the
mooring lines have a huge
circumference.
So there's not tremendous
concern about primary direct
entanglement from marine mammals
interacting with those cables.
However there is a concern that
marine debris and fishing gear
could become entangled in.
The very many cables within an
off shore floating [inaudible]
Wind farm. One of the reasons
that were so supportive of
starting small and then scaling
up developments incrementally is
to see how these interactions
between sea turtles and marine
mammals play out with cables.
In the field.
Citing offshore wind turbines
should prioritize avoiding
sensitive habitat areas then
requiring strong measures to
protect wildlife throughout each
stage of the development
process.
And then there should be
comprehensive monitoring.
Of wildlife and habitat before
during and after construction.
Following this framework of
avoidance.
Prioritizing avoidance is
essential for responsibly
developing offshore wind energy.
The next slide please
[inaudible]
Thanks.
And next [inaudible]
One thank you.
Now I'd like to discuss some of
the environmental considerations
specific to the humble call area
which you'll see up there
outlined in yellow.
On this side you'll see.
Our he said that the outline of
the humble call area -- So it's
hard to tell from this image but
one of the concerns that we have
is about the thank the
communities.
That live on the sea floor I
mentioned before that it's going
to be important to avoid placing
anchors and sensitive habitat.
There's limited information
about the Ben those of the
humble call area.
However in twenty sixteen if
there was some work -- Using an
autonomous underwater vehicle.
And that characterized to some
of the C. for habitat near the
call area.
The expedition found twenty
species of corals eight species
of sponges and eighteen species
of fish near the couple humble
call area.
This observe diversity and
density of species demonstrates
that a thorough Ben take survey
should occur in the call area to
identify areas with high levels
of diversity.
In order to minimize benthic
impacts it's also important to
note that the call area is
situated between two submarine
canyons one is your canyon to
the south and the other is
Trinidad canyon. To the north.
Even though we know one minute
great thank you very much. One
thing to note about the
submarine canyons is that they
are well documented to service
habitats nurseries forage areas
refugia in carbon sequenced
carbon sequestration and storage
areas.
It's unknown how development in
proximity to these canyons may
affect the canyon's ecosystem
functions and the services they
provide.
That's why starting small and
monitoring very carefully is
critical.
Finally it with regard to marine
mammals there at least thirty
species of marine mammals that
live in California coastal
waters the wood detailed
analysis for only a small number
of those occurring in the
offshore wind areas.
Has been conducted. For many of
the species with known
distributions the data are not
fine enough to make localized.
Decisions in a humble call area.
There's certainly a need for
better data on blue whales and
great wealth.
Among others I'm sure. To
conclude I'm going to underscore
some of the key research needs
and I can see that my time is up
and sell I will really conclude
quickly.
I'm I wanted to building on what
Jennifer mentioned about the
importance of prioritizing a
robust analysis of the existing
information that's in the
database and I also wanted to
add that having three years of
robust baseline data.
Has a great potential to
actually benefit the offshore
wind industry.
If you have a in in adequate
baseline that could lead to
profound delays in the future.
Energy C. looks forward to
working with the California
coastal commission ocean
protection council California
energy commission and bill meant
to ensure.
That offshore wind development
upholds the highest level of
environmental protections thank
you thank you so much we're
grateful to our pan -- We'd like
to be an open up some questions
here I would like to be to go --
To miss Ellsworth first so we
talked with my energy sees work
in the Atlantic -- Is our
ongoing monitoring -- Of what
you've seen deployed fill us in
on that and that's been an issue
that wanted that makes that we
address today.
That's a great question I am
not.
So here's what I can say about
--
Our work in the Atlantic we were
instrumental in developing --
Working with a regional planning
process and not is one of the
elements of offshore when
planning that we seem to be
really successful -- For example
the Rhode Island -- I'm sure
when development.
Undertook an extensive planning
process in which energy C. was
very active and part of that
process was identifying
important ecological areas so.
Some so that offshore wind
development was cited with those
in mind and as a result the
permitting for that project map
very quickly -- Another part of
our involvement has been working
really closely with developers
in that protection of the north
Atlantic right whale.
And after years of negotiations
--
Energy C. into other
environmental groups were.
Really proud to announce a
collaboration with Ben vineyard
when where the developer agreed.
To certain key mitigation
measures cell protecting right
wells from the acoustic impacts
of geophysical surveys and
undertaking.
Key construction activities
during periods where the wheels
were less sensitive.
So to summarize about our work
in that northeast I would say
that -- We've been very involved
in both -- Contributing to the
science and also -- Advocating
strongly to really elevate the
scientific.
Elevate citing that factors in
scientific considerations.
You know those mostly floating
platforms or they actually
drilled and can you just fuller
piled on Ben okay there yeah.
Right so.
In terms of floating.
Turbines -- There are there's
the project in Scotland and
there is no floating project in.
The United States right now
Connie thank you so much -- For
the three of you on going
monitoring is an important --
It.
Item that you'd like to be a C.
dressed.
Of both fisheries and wildlife.
Yes absolutely I mean with
without monitoring we don't know
what's happening and so given
especially the fact that it's
such a new technology and that
we don't know how well it will
work and what the impacts will
be.
Monitoring would be critical.
Thank you so much miss Ogan so
look at humble bays you said in
our entire read.
Tire north coast region -- It's
critical -- For back brand --
Why and -- Also if you could
just address that a bit -- And
then if you can also just
address ongoing monitoring and
if you think that is important
on one side.
Thank you -- Your grass grows
throughout the west coast from
my canteen.
On up most through the whole
west coast of North America on
up into the Alaska peninsula.
Your grass is the primary
component -- For forging black
Brant -- They migrate down to
Baja California and work away up
the coast -- In the fall and
work your way up to the coast.
Through the water time and then
--
Up to their breeding grounds in
the north slope of Alaska --
There are no populations of lack
of our Pacific Brent there are
non migratory seem to be hanging
around the a lot Alaska
peninsula.
And this is a product of global
climate change in which so large
is now reaching down to the
bottoms of the oceans there
where the you guys gets enough
sunlight to be able to produce
energy that they need to live --
I see this is an opportunity
with having platforms off shore
to be able.
To put monitoring devices on
these black brown to a large
body Berkeley usually Kerio.
Real color trance transmitted
formation -- As to where they're
migrating to wear their
marketing from when they're
migrating -- Elevation of their
migration the callers it'd been
developed so far that are being
used -- Collect information
numbers well they're moving
throughout the ocean and then
when they get near cell phone
cut tower.
It downloads information from
the last time that that color
was -- Downloaded -- Even to
even to downloading some
information awesome to G. towers
off of these species absolutely
no thank you and I just made a
note of that as well -- For the
three of you.
What I heard from to view is
it's important start I'm
paraphrasing here important
start formalizing -- The
feedback loop -- It especially
the closer we get to leases so
we may see leases in twenty
twenty twenty twenty one right
somewhere in that range.
And what I'm hearing is that it
would be -- For important
formalize the feedback loop from
stakeholders whether it's
environmental organizations
fishery groups -- As these
leases are getting closer -- To
being formalized please jump in.
I would say that's absolutely
correct and I mean this hearing
today has been so instructive in
the kind of conversations that
we need to be having.
And I as I said I think there's
a bit of a disconnect -- Where
we have on one hand?
This you know we're going we
have to get like we'd need
renewable energy like we
absolutely do there's Boston
about it -- But there is this
sort of pitch to the local
community about like we're going
to put in the softer wind farm
it's going to create a gazillion
jobs is going to solve all our
problems it's wonderful.
And maybe that's all true we
don't really have all the
information that we need that
and yes there's been eighty
meetings but a lot of those
meetings have been essentially
the same thing and it so.
You know that it's not like that
information is necessarily new
or that it's getting to new
people or that the and people
who are leading have as much of
an understanding an overview.
About what else is needed I mean
I feel like I've learned just
like I said so much today I
really appreciate this and
appreciate the other panelists
--
You have the so in making a
feedback loop that is more
formal more structured.
We can ideally get everybody on
the same page which I don't
think we are now and again.
Like we support renewable energy
on just be really clear about we
just want.
It all to all the information to
be up front and available to
everybody in the public we need
a balanced approach right yeah
--
We can't sacrifice one for the
other and by the way the reason
why we're moving forward
renewable energies at for the
planet right and so we have to
be able to have -- Forward
thinking and mitigation I once
we C. deployment please.
Short and just setting Ted Jen's
comments -- It's really
important to note that
California has experience in at
least -- Elevating environmental
considerations and other
stakeholder concerned so there
was that does renewable energy
conservation plan process that
went on for over a decade -- And
is still in place -- And there
it was also the San Joaquin
solar siting project wherein.
Least conflict areas for
development were developed in a
six month time frame so I think.
Going back to what John just
said it seems like there is
agreement that the sort of
process is necessary one that
includes lots of stakeholders
one that prioritizes
environmental concerns and those
of other stakeholders.
And so it's getting down to
brass tacks and sort of figuring
out what who's going to pay for
it who's going to convene at and
who should participate.
But again giving California's
experience I think that's
eminently doable it just needs
to happen and needs to become a
priority.
Thank you so much we're gonna
offer -- Very brief closing
comments anything that I may
have missed -- Or any items that
you would like to be able to
advance we'll start to my right
worker way dentre let's start
with Andy please -- Any closing
comments that you'd like to be
able to advance briefly.
Don't think of anything to add
other than -- Again I just
really wanted to thank you for
advancing this conversation.
You so much for being here in
super helpful -- In regard to
talking about where you've been
in the Atlantic as far as energy
C. -- And then also how we need
to be a formalized process thank
you so much please accept.
I don't have too much to ask but
I would just say that as a long
time not because president and
somebody who went through that
mean like protects not process.
And I think that it is very.
Clear that when and the state
agencies are working on projects
in the north coast that they
need to make a very.
Dedicated and determined effort
to understand the particular and
unique needs of this area and
address them.
And I appreciate your efforts in
that that world I guess machine
thank you so much for being here
check.
Hi sue this is an opportunity
now was. Five or ten years down
the road before we really see a
developing offshore wind farm.
To start doing office do start
doing research offshore also
these plastics pieces around her
finding out getting a bass line
and what's out there.
And then we'll see -- Once the
platforms are established and to
be able.
To continue that find out.
More information on what the
speeches are using our current
technology cameras and so on
like that too check the species
and then -- Begin to look at the
final results of that.
And I think of working with
shots energy and their program
and now looking at somebody
offers pieces is a good chance
to also work with them.
Thank you so much round of
applause for environmental
panels they take you so much
thank you for your time
[inaudible]
Grateful.
We're trying to get a present a
well rounded hearing here today
hearing from agencies in the
industry the environmental
organizations and now were
welcoming -- The fleet to be
able to come for our last panel
--
Is title California's fisheries
and offer winningest energy can
win in fish co exist or will the
plan flounder -- So we'd like to
be able to welcome.
I don't know if anyone noticed
the pan but you're very welcome
--
On a Friday we are gonna welcome
three individuals -- Here to the
table -- First and foremost so
we're gonna be hearing from
Harrison I. Bach is the
president of the humble
fisherman's marketing
association within can hear from
no Oppenheim the exact --
Director of the Pacific coast
federation of fishermen's
associations and we're really
grateful Andy Hawkins is here
she's the exact -- Director
responsible offshore development
alliance so we're gonna start
with yours and work our way down
to my right -- And we welcome
the three to the form thank you
so much. For being here try back
you have five minutes the floor
is yours and give you thirty
second prompt.
Thank you Sir McGuire.
My name is Harrison I. Bach I am
the president of humble
Fishman's marketing association.
The concept of offshore wind
energy is not new in other parts
of the world.
It is not new on the east coast
of the United States.
But the concept is new to the
west coast and especially here
in California.
What is known as the fact that
on the west coast of the United
States in a particularly
California we have some of the
most sustainable fisheries in
the world?
Here Fishman face many
challenges as our fisheries are
some of the most highly
regulated.
With gear restrictions in
limited fishing seasons.
But notably there also a large
amount of areas that are already
closed to fishing that exists in
this state.
We had marine protected areas
rock fish conservation areas.
Ascential fish habitat.
Marine sanctuaries.
Scott conservation areas in a
wide variety of other areas
already closed to fishing.
If one were to look at a map it
is quite simple to see that the
entire state is littered with
large areas that are already
closed to fishing.
These offshore wind energy
projects will permanently take
away an additional hundreds of
square miles of ocean from
fishermen as we are unable to
fish within these vast areas.
This convinces and ships more
fishing effort into the ever
increasing smaller areas that
remain.
We is fishermen in this state.
Utilize every last bit of these
remaining areas.
The bottom line is that we
cannot afford to lose anymore
essential fishing grounds.
Fishermen are also worried about
a long list of potential and
buyer environmental impacts most
of which have already been
mentioned the previous panel.
We understand firsthand how
harsh and unforgiving the ocean
can be and are concerned about
failures with the equipment or
even the entire project in
general.
There's also an element of
apprehension about the amount of
electricity being generated in
its effects on the marine
environment.
Yup sure win project also raises
many safety concerns the
proposed site for wind farm in
Eureka is going to take away
prime fishing grounds that are
critical to obtain due to these
close.
Due to be it being so closer
proximity to port.
It is also important to retain
these local grounds reduce
travel time in bad weather that
fishermen often face in northern
California.
They're also navigational
concerns here in Eureka fishery
must contend with a very
dangerous bar to transit to and
from the ocean.
Increasing the amount of
consistent traffic with very
large maintenance vessels in a
narrow area adds another element
of risk to safely pass.
Not only the bar but the fleet
must also be careful transiting
through the wind farm is there
will now be many large
obstructions we must avoid and
Dodge.
It will also increase traffic in
areas with ships traveling the
coast.
These are more hazards that a
fisherman must face to provide a
product that the public desires.
Wild sustainably caught seafood
is considered to be the absolute
best form of seafood on the
planet.
That we as fishermen strive to
make these viable resources
available.
Yeah it really seems that we are
always under attack.
Whether it's environmental
groups that fight to shut down
these fisheries.
Or government agencies
attempting to take away more
fishing grounds.
Fishermen are always fighting to
defend their livelihoods.
The public relies on us to
provide a wild sustainable
product by means of fishing.
And we rely on fishing for
survival.
Fishermen are not against
renewable energy at all.
But we are against permanently
losing fishing opportunity
[inaudible]
Thank you.
Thank you so much. For a great
for now then turn the floor over
to known Oppenheim the executive
director of the Pacific coast
federation of fishermen's
associations now welcome Sir.
Thank you chair McGuire it's a
pleasure to be here with you.
The state of California and the
people of the north and the
central coast have a lot to be
proud of in their commercial
fishermen and when it.
Our fisheries are among the most
sustainable in the world and
Fishman work tirelessly to
ensure that the public trust
resources that you the people
right we own.
There are the highest quality
the revenues from the harvester
shared for the public's benefit
and their bounty is available to
future generations of fishermen
and the public for ever.
And the economic activity of our
members and associates seafood
businesses in addition to
feeding the state and the world
provide a hundred and twenty
four thousand eight hundred jobs
at last count and over thirty
five billion dollars of economic
productivity that's in
California alone according to a
department of commerce.
Study clearly fisheries are an
important part of our coastal
renewable economy in California
and threats to these existing
jobs in the families they
support.
Should be free we discuss in
forums like this so.
Thank you for the opportunity.
Our state likewise takes pride
its ingenuity and the proactive
work that we take to reduce
carbon emissions we also take
pride in social justice in the
equity bill any of our major
projects and initiatives.
This become of renewed focus of
the new some administration in
for example the distribution of
our scarce water resources.
And for that we're grateful it's
in the spirit of that of of
equity billeted at the Pacific
coast federation of fishermen's
associations has been working
proactively to defend the rights
of our members.
And operate -- Imply their craft
in the context of wind energy
development off shore.
The state in the north coast
regions -- And the central coast
regions are poised to enter the
Brave New World of offshore wind
energy.
If we don't take care if we
don't learn from the mistakes
made in other parts of the U. S.
and other countries we will lose
a real opportunity to get this
right the first time.
Climate change and ocean warming
impacts the fisheries have been
numerous insignificant already
from shifting fish population
distributions to closures caused
by harmful algal blooms these
changes have been unpredictable
and sometimes extraordinarily
costly even tragic.
In addition to these climate
impacts regulatory and spatial
constraints of severely
constrained commercial fisheries
costing our members dearly.
The impacts the commercial
fishing industry resulting from
the development of offshore wind
resources are likewise numerous
insignificant from spatial
displacement the gear
concentration to business
disruption interruption to
impacts to safety transit.
And logistical impacts to shore
side operations.
From the fishing industries
perspective offshore wind
development is equivalent to
eminent domain.
It's crystal clear to us that
the fishing industry that
offshore wind area --
Development equates to closed
areas.
There's been the beneficiaries
of these closures will be
corporate entities foreign and
domestic to sell power to
consumers for profit.
It's the transfer of assets and
resources from one space
intensive ocean user group to
another in simple this is the
set of trade offs like any other
eminent domain process.
It's a choice for society and
for our leaders to make let's
make wise choices.
It's also clear to us that these
call areas beacons being
considered here today are just
the beginning. Thirty gigawatts
of generation and the result and
displacement of most commercial
fishing activity off our coast
appear to be the goal post where
could contemplating here today.
That's frightening to many.
We hear a lot about compensation
to fishermen in the in these
conversations disruption
payments D. impacted businesses
will certainly be appropriate
down the road.
If wind projects and cables are
installed in the U. S. easy in
our coastal waters we have a lot
of work to do first.
If offshore wind projects are
not appropriate for certain
areas of the coast based on
impacts of fisheries or under
the cesium a consistency process
we end the wind history industry
need to know this before leasing
takes place.
The outer continental shelf
lands act and the national
environmental policy act or to
broad legal frameworks that
require significant analyses
when development impacts to
commercial fisheries among
others.
But because Boeing maintains
that it is not reasonably
foreseeable that wind of element
will result from wind energy
leasing the full environmental
scoping process including
economic analyses will not take
place until after tens of
millions of dollars.
Poured into purchasing leases in
engineering studies.
This is backwards in my opinion.
The fishing industry knows what
these impacts are there will not
be fishing in wind energy areas
we can begin the scoping process
now we're grateful that after
years of that because he we are
starting to see the foundations
of economic studies taking
shape.
We need to look beyond single
studies and focus on developing
consortia to address specific
questions fishing communities
and when developers are starting
to engage tackle these
information challenges on the
east coast.
We could take a page from their
book here.
We also need to scope the
indirect impacts the commercial
fisheries appropriately there
are many scientific questions
that remain unanswered.
That must be it answer by
agencies developers before we'd
sell these facilities we need to
know whether floating when
structures aggregate fish stocks
result reducing access and
fisheries productivity we need
to know.
What the loss of federal fish
population survey stations will
mean for our stock assessments
and what management constraints
we can expect from uncertainty
being injected into the federal
management process?
We need to know about impacts to
radar and other navigation tools
we do there's no not only about
what impacts these projects
would have to sensitive.
And yes a listed species what
those impacts convene for
commercial fisheries that those
same species already
constrained.
We are heartened to hear that
the state agencies working on
this process are already working
on many of these coping
questions in our industry will
be a good faith partner these
efforts.
We have a lot of pride of faith
in California's CZ M. A.
consistency process and we will
not accept federal rollbacks of
our because the commission's
authority to enforce the coastal
act thirty seconds we are
obviously -- We all obviously
have a lot of work to do to get
this right.
And I look forward to working
with you senator and many of
those here in the room as we
move forward thank you.
Thank you so much seven I'm very
grateful we'll have some a
follow up in just a bit were so
appreciate any Hawkins is here
she's the exact address for the
response fostered about an
alliance.
Sagas the floor is yours you
have five minutes and give you
thirty second problem welcome.
Thank you and thanks so much for
inviting me to beautiful Eureka
that's a nice -- Diversion for
me from the usual D. C. life in
the east coast so angrily
rejected it the weather is like
this every day hi.
Yeah I've been here before.
Yeah.
Okay so -- My name is Anne
Hawkins and I'm the executive
director of the responsible off
shore development alliance or
Rhoda.
Which is based in Washington DC
road is a membership based
coalition of fishing industry
associations and fishing
companies.
With an interest in improving
the compatibility of new
offshore development with their
business sense.
We currently have members from
Maine to North Carolina.
On we provide a strength in
numbers approach to coordinating
science and policy initiatives
to minimize conflicts between
traditional and historic
fishing.
And other uses of the outer
continental shelf which as we
know are increasing rapidly.
I mean today's has money I'm
gonna focus primarily on
offshore when leasing process --
Mike happy right more
information on environmental
impacts the glass panel cover
that well.
And then I did submit a letter
for the record -- That we that
showing some of our concerns
with environmental impacts. One
of the biggest obstacles rodas
attempted to overcome is a lack
of information incorrect
information about offshore
development plans.
And the fact that they may or
may not have on fisheries note
ocean ecosystems. To be clear
him anyways offshore wind energy
development and sustainable
commercial fishing are directly
conflicting activities.
Unfortunately on the east coast
the rapid pace of offshore wind
development and the failure to
engage and transparent in early
engagement with fishing
communities.
Has led to leasing in project
design decisions being made
without effectively minimizing
impacts our stork sustainable
commercial fisheries.
Proper consideration of fishing
practices and management takes a
significant amount of time.
Often fishermen regulators are
being asked to provide
information for purposes.
And on special skills that I've
never had manager relevance
before so these data collection
analytical intimate activities
can take months or even years
together right.
The opportunities for public
input leasing process alone do
not occur often enough for early
enough to allow for meaningful
cooperation to reduce conflicts.
Fishermen must never be seen as
merely a stakeholder in the
anything off showing developers
are simply the newest
stakeholders to our into
California centuries old fishing
industry which provides the
state with your place will
benefits jobs revenue food
security tourism recreation.
Actual males on dinner plates
traditional ecological
knowledge.
And a significant contribution
to the states for a dining.
Sirota form last summer to
better amplified the concerns of
commercial fishermen and to
better include their expansive
knowledge and talk show in
development process.
And in some ways we found pretty
receptive audiences -- To that
and we recently signed a ten
year memorandum of understanding
with national marine fisheries
service and the bureau of ocean
energy management -- To
communicate fisheries import
better into the leasing process.
And Oregon scientific products
to better consider fisheries
impacts -- So through that M. O.
U. we've been able to work more
closely alongside our government
partners more often in the
process -- To enable us to
educate our fishing industry
membership.
Project development and to
provide feedback to both names
embalmer guarding the industry's
concerns.
We've also found it useful to
work with wind energy developers
directly -- We've invited
currently holding developers to
a joint industry task force that
we formed on the east coast. To
tackle some of the most
difficult conflict areas between
the two industries.
Working directly together --
Will help identify best
practices for up showing proper
projects and provide a forum to
drive innovative problem solving
--
The state and California
leaseholder shin braces club
reproach as well -- We find that
there's a lot of room for
innovation when people actually
talk about what's happening on
the water they might not come
out through the through the
leasing process.
A couple of houses Spokane to
mitigation -- On the east coast
aggressive state renewable
energy procurement goals --
Drive after when markets which
is a little different from here
I understand -- And at that
opens the door to variable
purchase to medication and to
destruction payments -- Among
projects among areas.
These discussions first and
foremost need to be transparent
and inclusive it is absolutely
imperative that fisheries
mitigation follows a step wise
approach.
First to avoid impacts they some
possible second to minimize any
accent absolutely can't be
avoided.
Then to mitigate any residual
impacts appropriate spatial
seasonal or technological
controls and then and only then
once those steps have been
followed.
Consider disruption payments for
fisheries losses.
Since the beginning of offer
when development projects or
spend the recognition of the
need for regional science body
to address research and
monitoring needs for fisheries
offshore wind interactions.
Not just on a project specific
level but to understand
ecosystem impacts from the large
scale installation of these new
industrial projects.
As well as the cumulative
impacts of Malta police sites --
The relationship that wrote it
has bill with government
agencies now for wind energy
developers.
Has allowed us to assist in the
formation of a new five oh one
C. three at the response washer
science alliance a rose up just
affiliated -- Which is a
collaborative effort among
fishing industry representatives
offer when developers and state
and federal government agencies.
We're working to increase alien
incredible data on fisheries and
when development and to increase
the understanding the effects of
wind energy development on
fisheries and the ocean eco
systems on which they depend.
Thirty seconds California must
similarly develop and support
collaborative and initiatives to
increase scientific
understanding research
monitoring.
Which is paramount to achieving
future co existence.
We found a road on the hope to
minimize the divide and conquer
approach to interacting with
commercial fishermen and rapidly
developing ocean.
Our successes of come from our
ability to collaborate with
fishermen and fishing related
businesses will be affected by
wind energy.
Fishermen hold a broad range of
beliefs and approaches to their
interactions with other ocean
users but they're also the
single best source of
information about the offshore
environment.
This information has to be
brought to bear and constructive
in time appropriate manner in
order to ensure that one
renewable resources and
developed at the expense of
another thank you.
Thank you so much nice work
really grateful would like me to
open up for questions if it
works for the three of you.
Would like me to start with
Dropbox tell us about -- You
know we heard that that the
association is in M. O. U. --
With printable power don't wanna
say get into the exact details
M. O. U. but what are you trying
to be able to accomplish to be
able to protect the fleet --
Well I've always like that
saying -- If you don't have a
seat at the table you're on the
menu yeah but I think that when
it comes to offshore wind energy
with commercial fishermen -- We
are trying to make is that we do
have a seat at the table.
But we are always going to be on
the menu.
Yeah in you talked about losing
valuable ground right -- That
would otherwise be utilized for
commercial fishing.
If you wanna talk about any of
the other specific concerns to
humble -- That we should be
aware of that we should be
looking at as we move forward.
All.
I mean.
Like I stated and in my
testimony -- There's so many
closures already in California.
We've just been bottlenecked
into all of these other confined
areas.
And if we take away more grounds
hundred square miles of area.
I mean all we're doing is
pushing us further and further
in contention as work it's
efforts shifted into smaller and
smaller areas.
So all over ground is very
valuable it doesn't matter if we
were to move it to the north or
moved to the south.
The bottom line is that we can't
afford to lose anymore grounds.
The challenges and one of the
boards your mouth is the
cumulative impact of what you've
seen over the past many years
with -- Closures with -- Areas
that are now off limits except
raise that would that be
accurate yes okay thank you
thank you very much would like
me to go to miss Hawkins -- Can
you give us a rundown of best
practices that you've heard of
it that you've seen in that
you've implemented -- And then
any lessons learned that would
be good for all of us to hear
about especially as we go
forward with his burgeoning
industry.
Sure so in terms of best
practices it's can this is
surely give you a run down
because we're still working on
them I mean sure so a lot of
ways to go all right -- The
lane.
For sure -- I mean.
Like I said it's it's getting
the industry's together is
getting the fishing industry to
the table early and often and
not just to check a box not just
you know we've we've.
Heard here today you know we've
had any meetings we've heard on
these guys about a hundred fifty
meetings on this project.
But fishermen don't know where.
Where their input is best given
into the process they're not
gonna bring that information
effectively -- And a lot of it
has to be driven by the fishing
industry is should not ever feel
like something that's being
imposed on one industry by
another.
If the truth if the culturally
as to to work together -- It's
really you know.
Co exist or are being more
compatible -- So I would say you
know is start everything early
start your economics impacts
studies early start your
ecological surveys early you
know now if you if you know
what's coming now.
Start working on it now -- And
don't wait until you know you've
got the short deadlines with a
with the permitting process.
You mentioned thank you -- You
mention -- There were some
conflict areas -- That had
started to evolve.
What can we learn here in the
Golden State about what you're
seeing is conflicts?
Back east.
What can I mean there's a lot of
specific ones in sort of more
general once I mean one one
thing that comes to mind that
that's really obvious one is
that the first few -- Leases
that were issued on the east
coast were issued without any
consideration of fishing vessel
transit so even if you assume
that there is gonna be closer to
finishing.
You know you have people that
are going to fishing grounds on
other on the other side how are
they going to get through that
array and and in New England we
have a fourteen hundred square
mile complex now.
Lee says that just keep going on
to each other.
You know for fishermen on
lobster boat across fourteen
hundred square miles is no joke
right -- But once the developer
holds a lease and has developed
the their their pricing and send
the procurement contracts with
the state -- It becomes very
difficult for them to remove
rows of turbines to allow for
fishing vessel access that
should have been written into
the lease that should have been
done up front.
And now we're starting to one
that that's the type of thing
that you can look up a friend
there's a lot of other examples
like that but that's that's a
pretty good.
One that said thank you. For the
valuable feedback on night.
Thanks very good M. shopping
hime -- It is about how you like
to be a C. a formal process
develop -- That would include
the fleet -- Here in the months
and years to come.
That's a critically important
question obviously.
The I I think engagement with
the the OPC.
Social protection.
Cancel end the coastal
commission are the places to
start I think we we need to
start.
Taking the initiative here in
California -- Start having stir
creating a forum for
conversations with the the
developers the wind industry --
Who also are seeking certainty
in the space I I completely
understand that -- That that's
the model it's clearly the one
that's demonstrating the
greatest degree of success on
the east coast -- And we are
we're taking the baby steps now
but without question our
organization the Pacific coast
federation of fishermen's
associations the local
associations closest and
proximity. To the wind energy
call areas and other
associations of fishermen who do
operate in these areas as well
the to be at the table we've.
Started on our industry side to
have those conversations they'll
continue -- And and we will
continue to maintain the style.
We heard feedback I am gonna
have to wrap it up because we
want to make sure that we
provide time for folks to be
able to provide comment as well
we've heard feedback.
About ongoing monitoring.
In the importance of that -- In
being able to have real time
feedback if -- We have
challenges.
How important as it is that to
the three view -- As well as far
as the on going munching a
communication to fleet in being
able to build that into any
agreements.
I'll start with -- Here seem to
work our way down in -- I just
think it's crucially important
that over this process for the
next -- As it was stated maybe
five years -- That.
The fleet really has a say in
and how this is done and we
really hope that this is done
right -- For magnitude research
not just for fisheries but also
for environmental impact as well
--
I don't wanna say we'll have one
shot reading this right but it
really seems that we really do
only have one shot at getting
this right.
And so I really hope that --
There's further dialogue in a
lot more discussion with Ford
with -- As we go through this
process thank you so much your
of course three with their sins
comments -- Monitor is
critically important.
We need to set bass lines now
those include economic bayside's
human use bass lines -- But we
can't.
Do monitoring.
In the sense of learning from
mistakes and and pulling back
from the break so to speak.
If it's an all or nothing
proposition with respect to
development -- I'd love to see
the state take a real interest
in internet approaches --
Whether that be some sort of
smaller scale operational
implementation -- Putting ten
turbines in the water instead of
a hundred to start monitoring
the situation there.
And then determining whether or
not these projects are
appropriate or if there are any
anticipate unanticipated.
Impacts.
I have a project if you will
something like that right yeah.
Absolutely thank you so much.
Echo everything they said --
Your Monning is critically
important but it's only
wanderings only valuable if you
have the correct building blocks
on either side one is that it
you know if you're monitoring
and you see an impact -- You see
an effect that maybe you didn't
anticipate or maybe is worse
than you thought what do you do
about it so unless you have an
action plan for what comes out
of the monitoring.
The Monning in of itself isn't
very helpful and you also need
to be able to effectively
monitor you need baseline
information.
And that.
In terms of fisheries takes a
long time to get and you know
one or two year time series of
what's going on and in the
spatial.
Areas is not going to tell you
what you need to know thirty
years now to see what changes
are you need to get.
Started on those types of
studies and designing those
research needs as soon as soon
as possible.
Has there been -- In my
ignorance and I apologize has
there been compensation for loss
of vision or anywhere else
fishing gear -- No anywhere else
in the world or on the east
coast has there been discussion
about data compensation for the
fleet.
There have been payments made --
In in Europe so in.
In the U. K. fishing is allowed
in wind energy or is in the rest
of Europe it's not and so.
The rest of Europe it was very
easy to sort of nationally
decide what to do with with.
Fishing with fishermen who are
displaced right because you know
they're moving -- In the UK
there were payments on the east
coast there's payments in
discussion and I wouldn't know
if any checks Ben cut but but
yes -- Unfortunately a lot of
those discussions happened early
in the process -- Before any
impacts are minimized and that
isn't going to keep people
fishing that's a that's a good
way to to pay off people that.
That would like to retire anyway
--
Doesn't doesn't do much for
training fishermen in keeping so
vicious animal M. will follow up
on this as well but the sockets
I don't mean that paper you
twenty questions so thank you
for your patience.
So wide that describe the
difference between Great Britain
and then the rest C. Europe of
allowing fishing around.
Wind turbines and then -- Off
limits elsewhere.
It has something to do with the
Magna Carta and public trust
writes in the okay and if you
can yeah.
That's enough for today.
It's it's some that will follow
up on in -- On that have you
heard of any conflicts so with
when industry and at the fleet
though -- I've been able to fish
around I turbines has there been
any challenges a lot of
challenges a lot art will
definitely follow up on that
thank you so much we're gonna
look to closing comments briefly
please or start with miss
Hawkins.
Then Mr out -- Oppenheim Mister
I bought please I just want to
thank you again for for bringing
me here and I'm happy to be a
resource anytime that I can
provide more information to the
community or to the city or to
anyone -- Working on this thanks
thank you so much.
Thank you very briefly -- Thank
you for creating this forum for
allowing the industry.
To have a spot at the table --
And it without question we we
need strong wise leadership in
the future so be looking to you
and to the committee for that.
And I would just add that we we
have an extraordinary
opportunity here to learn from
mistakes the the state agency.
Staff who we've spoken with
recently are up to the task and
we look forward to supporting
their work.
Thank you so much trouble -- I
just want to let it be known
that if anyone would like to
have any further discussion
regarding any of this small is
open and available otherwise
thank you very much senator for
allowing us to speak.
Absolutely in a in a promise you
will be following up with each
and everyone of you -- We want
take moment say thank you to our
panelists give a round of
applause please.
In leasing Jim is Hawkins gets
the word for traveling the
furnace to so -- Thank you so
much for coming -- Away from the
east coast.
Now we'd like to be able to open
it up -- For public coming out
we're gonna start out -- In
again want to say thank you to
the redwood coast energy
authority we like to have their
executive record to be able to
come forward -- Who will lead us
off in public comment -- Each
individual who will be speaking
at will have two minutes to be
able to address the committee --
And on behalf of the committee
we want to say thank you for
hanging with us -- And hang with
us. For the morning and now into
the afternoon I were welcoming
M. at the marshals the executive
director of the red because
energy authority have been real
leaders here in the north coast
on the issue of wind energy we
welcome you Sir and want to say
how much we appreciate.
Your work the floor is yours --
Thank you know that I'll be
brief M. for those that are
familiar that right because
Senate youth already is that
local government joint powers
agency here in humble county.
And our mission is to develop
sustainable energy initiatives
on behalf of the county and all
of our member cities.
At and we are also responsible
through committee J. segregation
for the electricity supply part
of electricity service here so
we're we're responsible for
procuring the power that that
the power symbol county.
And and so as part of that you
know we're obviously interested
in moving towards the state
goals are local goals of a 100%
renewable power.
And I'm sure win is that is a
huge potential there and so did
to your point you know I think
we're also as a local public
agency very committed. To not
wanting to have our power be at
the expense of you know.
Unacceptable impact
environmental or fishing and you
know concerns and so I think you
know are proactive approach has
been really to not be.
Sort of passive and hope that
this moves forward in a way that
our community finds acceptable
and that addresses environmental
and fishing concerns and so.
You know make my board is really
--
I think been -- Bolden saying we
want to get in front of this we
don't want to just you know hope
we get a lucky developer that
really cares about these things
as much as we do.
And so that's why we've been
very active in trying to to get
in front of it and and move this
forward with really a community
driven process with
environmental concerns in the
fishing community and that the
entire community.
With a true seat at the table in
the decision making and not
being in a responsive reactive
mode and so we're we're looking
for to kind of continue that
process and you know we have to
work within the framework of the
bomb process and and obviously
of course that.
The state environmental --
Regulatory process and that were
we're eager to move that forward
and we appreciate you having
this event up here in humble
county in non Sacramento and you
know.
We look forward to kind of
continuing the local dialogue
really having this conversation
here in our community as this
goes forward.
Thank you no thank you so much
in our C. A. allies really set
the standards are do appreciate
that Sir and please pass our
thanks your board as well.
We'd like to be able to bring
forward I. individuals who now
would like to Ben speak we're
gonna queue up right over here
to the microphone.
If you don't mind is given as
your first name and if you are
with an organization
organization thank you again for
being with us you have two
minutes please -- Dennis mail
became legal before started like
to tell the community that I we
we need to have our thoughts and
prayers for McKinley bill.
Hello high school today we we
had a a young person that seems
--
Committed suicide cancel the
trickle of closed and all of our
our prayer should go out to the
the the children there the
family it's just a real bad deal
so.
Thank you for indulging me and I
don't think you so much okay --
I'm Josh mail and wear many hats
--
You said I was from a chemical
committee serves a district
which is correct and we are a
member of this energy deals
where that hat that I wear --
Also I worked on drilling rigs
all over the country I worked on
these platforms that floating
don't float so -- I don't have a
negative opinion about that and
I also support of alternative.
But also support that we need to
use our natural gas which is
fluent mental have lot of
disagreement about that but that
needs to be one of the other.
Tools we have in our toolbox --
You know the the all of these
things out really good in the
hall to legislate your and on
paper.
But when they come down to those
of us that actually produce.
It's a different scenario -- It
really it really -- Sure let me
let me cut to the chase I I I.
riven California commercial
beach fisherman.
Okay these guys for fish but
they also are local crabbers
there cooking line fishermen
they're the guys to produce this
great sustainable product that
we need.
We don't get the we don't get
the support we need from our
state and I know you reach out
to us Mike we're having
discussions right now about the
crab closure the ridiculous clap
crab closure.
So everyone of these things that
happen.
Look out.
It's going to be good -- These
guys will protect us we don't
trust none of that because it's
not that not be in our history.
The M. P. age that are out there
have cut out a huge portion of
our fishing.
Unnecessarily this whole region
is an MPA practically put the
slayings on land.
Or put him in the M. P. A.'s
what you're just research areas
anyway they're not they're
they're not they're designed to
produce fishing for us -- What
other things it will communicate
in writing with you -- I know
this.
Is gonna happen.
Okay who who are not stupid
we're just trying to figure out
which I we want you to Galgiani.
Thank you thank you so much to
mail it your comments in thank
you for being here and thank you
for leading off -- On that
recognition as well and the
tragedy in making the bill's
going.
No it is it is thank you so
much.
Sir we welcome you thank you --
My name is Tyler studs I'm with
ET P. renewables -- I lied --
The project manager for the red
because doctor when project -- I
bring to that -- About ten years
experience in after when
industry including eight with
the state of Massachusetts --
Leading the state's investments
in multi year multi million
dollar baseline wildlife surveys
--
The three points I want to make
our number one to speak directly
to the question posed in this
panel -- I do believe that after
wind wildlife and fisheries are
compatible your work committed
to making that actually be -- D.
a yes -- I do believe that there
are very good lessons learned
but that each project is unique
and those lessons learned are
more in the process of how we
create that then in the science
findings themselves -- The third
point is that we are I believe
that we are on the right track
--
So in terms of lessons learned
in process sees -- I echo what's
been shared by many of the
panelists already and credit you
for putting together phenomenal
panel now -- Multiple panels.
In the process it's key
obviously to be engaged early
and often with your all of the
key stakeholders.
Jointly scoping and identifying
key research questions is
critically important both on the
fisheries level and on with --
With wide life -- Advocates in
it and non profits -- We are as
an industry engaging early right
now with -- Key environmental --
Agent actually in vinyl not non
profits to identify how we can
together jointly scope those
pricing join these couples
questions and implement those.
So I will lastly just advocate
you know that this it's
critically important the state
make investments -- Improvement
conducting you know early
baseline wireless surveys be
able to deal with existing data
already to analyze those in the
context of archer wind -- And
that yeah.
We do that you know in a very
high priority way.
So -- I really appreciate this
opportunity provide comments and
thank you very much again for
not Ted thank you so much we're
gonna have I. T. there are
currently get your card is well.
I before you leave thank you so
much I know Tom as your contact
contact information as well.
Good morning actually good
afternoon -- Do apologize for
the weight thank you for hanging
with this the floor's yours me
if you just give us first name
thank you -- I'm surely allows
government affairs coordinator
and tribal member of Trinidad
rancheria thank you for and I'm
sure that.
Has been of a founding member of
the the state balm a task force.
And so the early engagement.
It was conducted with tribes and
I just want to say like
everybody else I said today
early and qualitative engagement
is critical.
And everything is connected and
everything needs balance.
And that true that rancheria we
own and operate -- Trinidad
harbor and so we work closely
with the Fisher the local
fishermen that fish out of
Trinidad.
And we also own a crab boat so
we're directly impacted with --
Many aspects of the discussions
that are happening today so
we're following this process and
were actively engaged and I just
wanna -- Put in -- A plug -- For
TKA the tribal -- Ecological
knowledge and that that isn't a
forgotten or not included when
you're looking at the scientific
--
Information aspect thank you
says thank you so much really
grateful that you're here
providing that perspective and
you left out the you make good
chatter it C. skate.
So -- It's a really good but at
thank you very much and please
pass center.
Thanks to the board as well
thank you so much it's good to
see you and thanks for being
here.
Good afternoon and thank you for
hanging with us the floor is
yours.
Thank you senator gore.
Appreciate us having this
meeting in the first place -- My
name is Suzanne a tia I'm an
investor for the California
coastal national monument
system.
Based out of Trinidad -- With
association -- In association
with the only M..
The turnout museum in the
Trinidad coastal land trust.
In the spirit of saving what was
left of our great read words we
have to be careful not to give
away what we can't get back.
I'd like to speak for those who
have no voice and a no on or not
at this meeting right now.
The other trust the mirror lets
the puffins frigate birds turns.
Pelicans and so many others some
of which circumnavigate the
globe with their ancient and
historic flights.
Wind farms are currently doesn't
meeting birds and bats --
Mitigation and avoidance.
Are not currently successful on
land.
Why should we think it will be
off shore?
A local sub species of bat will
become extinct within the next
ten years to land based wind
energy.
It is a current on it is a
current ongoing problem which
has not been solved.
The birds may be out of sight do
not but do not let them be out
of mind.
They depend on us to protect
them.
That's it thank you city thank
you so much and thank you for
being here today were grateful
for your comments and your
testimony.
Taking notes on well good
afternoon it's good to see you
Sir welcome if two minutes.
Thank you Mister chairman.
For providing this opportunity
today -- My name is Dave built
some a local crap and salmon
fisherman.
Actually fish salmon -- As far
south as fibers -- I want to
thank -- Of want to talk about
the the business of involving
the fishing community early in
the discussions.
And I want to thank our C. eight
E.. Eight for doing that to the
extent that we've actually
signed and M. O. U. with them.
One thick principal power like
was for reaching out to
fishermen.
There a couple of things that
need to be included in not out
reach -- The first is -- The
issues of of transit of the
harbor -- Of the footprint of
the cable it's going to come
ashore.
What are the consequences of of
that cable going to be?
Order fishing grounds which it
most of go through -- Are we
going to be able to continue to
come and go.
From Humboldt Bay to fishing
grounds at the time of our
choosing rather than at someone
else's pleasure that needs to be
discussed soon.
And the other thing is -- I
heard today for the first time
that there's an anticipated
expansion if this works. Two of
a production on the order of
twenty gigabytes -- That could
be great for the state of
California could be good from
all day.
Where is the footprint for that
expansion going to be?
All presumably the of humble
call area and the Morrell big
call area or the best available
sites.
And we're looking at maybe two
hundred megawatts from those
sites we're looking at we we
just heard about a proposed
hundredfold expansion.
Of offshore wind production.
Our I would like to see.
The energy industries maps as
much as they want to see the
fishing industries maps -- We
have to do that before we get
much farther with this expansion
to twenty gigs.
Thank you thanks much for C.
Bates program for free here if
you continue to work on behalf
of the fleet thank you so much
for coming today.
All right.
Good afternoon thanks for Janet
Scott seeder your two minutes my
name is Nancy Kirschner
Rodriguez and I am here today
representing the business
network. For offshore wind.
The network as we like to be
called we're a nonprofit
organization solely focused on
the development of the U. S.
offshore wind industry.
And the advancement of its
supply chain.
We are -- Consider ourself and
if Thor's Tatum voice for the
offshore winds business
community we bring together.
Developers policy makers global
experts and we have more than
three hundred member businesses
including numerous labor unions
for critical discussions and
unprecedented.
Networking opportunities we just
held our sixth international
partnering forum and many of
these speakers here today.
Participated with us and a 100%
of our resources are focused on
the offshore wind -- Supply
chain development we try to be
an advocate for our members were
dedicated to building business
across sectors into a coherent
supply chain.
That supports domestic wind
farms and really establishes the
United States as a global
competitor in the offshore wind
market -- We were started in --
Twenty twelve in Maryland and we
have grown -- To a significant
number of as I said across the
the state -- Obviously our work
here our work here began in
twenty sixteen and I want to
thank -- Tom as well -- In
twenty eighteen we held our
floating frontiers.
Meeting and produce an
environmental -- Impacts paper
from that and that is on your
website we appreciate that we
look forward to continuing to
work with you one example that I
would just site is that we have
worked a lot with -- Jeff the
British government and we have
obtained -- Information about
their debt Brent work with the
broadly with the fishing
industry and they are very
interested in.
Working further with you on
discussion so I would look
forward -- To helping us
facilitate that as well and we
just look forward to being a
strong partner in.
The numerous dialogues and also
in the regulatory and
legislative process thank you so
much.
Thank you for travelling humbled
as well we're grateful you're
here.
All right we're gonna lock me
ma'am.
Good afternoon thank you for
hanging with this is good to see
you you have two minutes to four
stores good afternoon thank you
so much for putting together
this excellent yeah -- Hearing
and I want to say I've been to
many -- Meetings on this topic
and this is by far the most
informative I've been.
To mostly because of the
diversity of voices an interest
that have been represented here
--
I think it's really important to
have these types of meetings so
that we can all hear the the
concerns of different interest
groups -- Humble bee keeper -- I
forgot to say my name is
Jennifer calls I'm the director
of mobile bay keeper.
Thinking and we're very hopeful
that wind energy can help
California meet our renewable
energy targets -- In large part
because we really need to slow
down the effects of climate
change which are -- You know
having a a cumulative of a fact
on not only marine resources but
the fishing industry so ocean
acidification toxic algae.
Sea level rise are all serious
problems here in Humboldt Bay --
I've been really relieved to
hear so much discussion about
the need for a baseline
information to do appropriate
citing for this -- Project --
And then also we really need to
have an appropriate scale.
And having stakeholder
engagement that's a meaningful
early on as been talked about
many many times by many people
that is really critical.
And looking out the the wide
range of companies that
responded to the call -- I am
really hopeful that our redwood
coast energy authority will have
priority -- Because they are a
board of elected officials that
represent the local interest and
so we really need input from.
Local experts as well as far you
know experts from elsewhere --
We really need local
stakeholders we need the tribal
representatives -- We need
everybody to be participating in
the US and certainly we need a
lot more information about the
resources offshore -- Before we
launch into this so it as an
environmental advocate I just
want to really emphasize the
point that we're hopeful that
the environmental impact
analysis.
Citing mitigation monitoring can
all be done.
As well as possible so that we
can actually have a successful.
Renewable energy project here
thank you and Richard thank you
so much thanks for coming today
for all your work.
Discounts when yes I got a work
on councilman member it -- City
for dell but I'm also have been
very involved in the redwood
region economic development
commission.
And I think this has some.
Great potential for our area for
economic development -- At the
same time however -- I think we
really need to go out and and
look at best practices or people
that have gone before us in
other parts of the world.
I'm sure there are other
countries other companies that
are -- Leaders in this area that
are known for their best
practices hopefully or and or
have learned from their
mistakes.
So I'm hoping that will really
do that research to be able to
bring the best practices before
we before we step in the wrong
direction or do leases.
We also need to make sure and
I'm sure through the process it
sounds like again we bought some
great state colors together
thank you.
So much for doing that stern
McGuire -- And everyone that has
been involved here I think
that's great -- I do hope that
will mitigate for any a water
fell fax -- Four I hope we will
also -- Do cover the sustainable
concerns of the fishing
industry.
And and their ability to
navigate their ability -- To
continue to create their own
livelihood it's a great industry
and I I hope that can continue.
To other thought several quick
ones -- One is -- That we well
one other basically.
If we do go forward I'm hoping
that we take a look at this.
I remember the old internet
thing where you started out with
a category three or then you
went to five and then you went
I'm hoping that if we are we do
have the potential to do a
project program like ten when
mills or whatever.
And then we're thinking of
expanding this along the coast
or whatever areas.
That we build the capacity up
front if we're gonna make a
major investment in regards to
getting this on shore -- I I
hope we don't skinny on it but I
hope we have the line capacity
to really -- To really expand
out.
So that we don't have to make
the investment twice -- Because
we need to look at it forty
fifty years out and and what we
can really do with it if it is
successful so thank thank you
for being here.
Thank you so much has been great
for for your testimony today
thank you very.
And hang with us good afternoon
you've been here since this
morning thank you so much it's
good to see the floor is yours
your two minutes.
Answer -- My name is Brad Wilson
and you read as a graduate of
the renewable or the
environmental resources
engineering program H. issue --
I see the potential of wind
energy as a real asset -- I I'm
an advocate -- This was a
brilliant meeting today -- It's
all grew up front stakeholder
coordination across a wide
spectrum that these sorts of
things are going to be
successful -- Those things be
noted -- A wind farm off shore
of any size -- Really as as
locally reported as confirmed by
Larry -- To Kerr -- Harbor
district yeah commissioner --
Significant upgrades are
required to report -- The four
were really able to do anything
off shore so hundred ten working
surfaces new.
Ports -- Potentially expanded
infrastructure in transmission
and distribution.
All those things -- The policy
table -- Brought it up as a
potential issue -- The industry
table -- Brought it up again --
That.
Often times.
The legislature or the local
government is called upon to
kind of overcome some of those
initial baseline.
Things to pave the way for
industry to pave the way for a
developer to come in.
I was originally crafting this
is a question to you but
realizing you don't.
Actually have the ability to
respond I would suppose it's an
encouragement. For the the
California legislature to
consider.
The predecessor tasks that
require significant funding --
You know hundreds of millions of
dollars to upgrade the
infrastructure to even attempt.
An offshore wind farm given the
wind farm is you know. Ten
fifteen years out of all these
process or tasks -- The ability
to upgrade the port all of those
things need to happen before and
as a way to attract -- Industry
to our area -- As example by
cases in Europe -- So assuming
you don't have the ability to
respond California legislature
is working on anything like
that.
I would encourage us to consider
those things moving forward.
No thank you miss Wilson and
I'll just take a brief moment
and I know that we have several
speakers -- Keep it less than
sixty seconds I think it's it's
key that we look at what those
potential up front costs will be
for the infrastructure.
In what it would take to be able
--
To develop that.
In our neck of the woods I think
that you're gonna have to
significant driving costs. One
on the ground for the port.
The second I when it comes a
transmission line -- The state
has assisted.
Specific renewable energy on
transmission in the past --
Through -- Greenhouse gas
emission reduction funds.
And that is not even begin been
considered on this issue on this
project let alone across the
state for offshore wind but I
promise you it's something that
--
We will take a look at I would
love to keep in touch and if
it's okay.
Thank you thank you so much as
was appreciate that.
Welcome Sir good afternoon.
Thanks for hanging with us.
Thank you Sir McGuire into the
joint committee for sponsoring a
terrific meeting I think it's
just because of that it's been
quite valuable thank you.
My name is Scott Frazier my
consulting wildlife biologist
from the lake California.
Early on in the on land when
development hats be I was able
to work on some of those
projects where there was a high
degree of trial and error
learning.
And that is certainly not what
we want to see here off shore in
a very difficult work
environment.
So I think that -- It's
important that the baseline
studies occur and the research
be done before leases or sign so
I'm here to strenuously agree
with and support the comment no
open I made about.
Doing that work to know the
impacts before the leases are
signed.
Is important and I think they
can C. determination with the
state agencies might be a good
venue for that.
I'd also like to echo Jan
savages comment about the
quality of information meetings
and again today you made a
really great start on that.
I likewise have been to several
meetings but it's basically the
same information we heard the
previous ones.
The maximum future expansion
offshore should be described.
Due to both the fisheries access
issues have been addressed in
the environmental impacts that
have been discussed earlier.
So I think this idea about doing
a ten tower project and then
well if it works out we'll do
some more.
Is maybe not the way to
adequately plan for a project
that many people are here to
endorse.
So mapping the maximum potential
now would be important.
I'm here to speak for the
migratory birds that don't get
to vote and other wildlife
generally.
And I hope they should be given
full consideration along with
the human economic impacts
including.
Fishing and the other --
Livelihoods that people have the
I. concerns of thank you for
your time.
Patricia refer your here today
thinks ring with us along.
Good afternoon ma'am it's good
to see you thank you so much for
being here.
Hi I'm Stephanie did well
executive director of friends of
the river.
And organization adamantly
vehemently agrees that we need a
bold action to draw down our
reliance on climate destroying
fossil fuels.
That said we have some serious
concerns about the potential
impacts of this project.
I think in its its worst case
scenario -- These a floating
offshore wind farms have the
potential to cause pretty
significant harm to both.
Aquatic an avian life and I'm
I'm encouraged to hear that the
this is a long term plan that
people are going into this
looking at citing in mitigation
very carefully.
But I just I want to put this
back in the context of of this
region and the greater home okay
region.
And the fact that we are doing
so much restoration work right
now to save our some on it's
species we're taking out dams
were doing estuary restoration
and yet.
Our salmon are still struggling
our our our fisheries in general
are still struggling in our
fishermen are struggling as we
deal with things like the the
early closure.
On crabbing and so when we start
looking at adding in what.
Everyone in this room it minutes
or potentially significant
environmental impacts to a
region that has historically
been.
A salmon stronghold in the
struggling.
I have to question where this
fits in our long term thinking
in terms of truly sustainable
energy.
And I I look forward to engaging
in seeing how this goes but I do
think that we need.
To really think of in the local
context.
For how are we going to savor
salmon and what is the
significance of the impacts of
the supposed to it.
Thank you thank you thank you
for your testimony today and
again thank you for being here
with us for so long as well.
Thank you so much.
Good afternoon and welcome. For
yes Monning.
Senator McGuire and now Mister
west low for bringing everyone
here together.
My name is Mary Collins I'm a
visiting scholar at the
California institute for energy
environment and I also direct
the American jobs project -- And
we recently wrote a report
collaboration actually many
people in the room collaborated
on this report now which I'm
very grateful -- For and we
looked at this opportunity that
we have to build a new industry
from the ground up and and
asking how we're gonna do this
in a way that's gonna create.
Win win solutions for the
environments for fishermen --
You know and for labor -- Really
to spark a new wave of
innovation in our state.
And as I sit here today I see
that we have a lot of work to do
--
And you know we need to have
investment from the state of
California so we can do the
study so we can start to build
these process sees -- And really
create meaningful connections
with -- You know the U. K.
that's been brought up today
there's a lot of great key
studies there administer clear
Perry just had her.
Off shore hurt but the Osher
when sector deal that came out
that looks at the supply side
and they want.
To share information and
knowledge with California in a
meaningful way we've got a lot
to learn we also have a lot to
potentially offer.
Their industry -- So I just want
to conclude with the fact that
you know this is an enormous
opportunity to build this new
industry from the ground up --
And I'd be happy to share case
studies that we've been looking
out over the years with
successes from the offshore wind
industry and hope that we can
continue this conversation in a
meaningful way.
I would love M. is Connie thank
you so much in in time you'll
want to get together please let
us know Andy under to sit down.
Thank you so much for joining us
today thank you good afternoon
thank you so much for being here
the floor source you have two
minutes okay thank you our my
name is Steven Coleman I am.
That third division commissioner
for the humble bay harbor
recreation and conservation
district.
And also the community
development and resilience
director for the blue lake
rancheria tried so.
Juggling two hats here -- Like
everyone is that a good thank
you for this -- Holding this
form and holding a hearing
Eureka as you're well aware of
any kind of development.
You're on the north coast
requires frequent and meaningful
stakeholder consultation and
engagement so appreciate that.
Especially with the fishermen
with the tribes with labor and
everyone else here -- There's
been a lot of dressed here I
agree and believe that any
development must be taken
carefully with the needs of the
current stakeholders in mind
especially with the fishermen.
Including -- In port development
of which there is the
opportunity to do a lot we have.
Unused infrastructure here at
that.
Could use an influx of money in
an influx of development and
jobs but all that needs to be
done compatible with the fishing
industry.
And not just not bringing harm
but also bringing benefit and I
think there's ways that can be
done to do that.
And I just wanna and with what.
Hasn't been said and probably
everyone considers doesn't
doesn't need saying but I still
think you know one of our
biggest impacts out there is
ocean acidification.
And ocean warming and the only
way we're going to have any
chance of slowing that down
even.
Reversing that but just slowing
down those horrific impacts to
the fisheries to life on this
planet is to a rapid shift.
Towards renewable energy such as
this and so.
I would just encourage everyone
what we're looking at the M.
packs. To the environment to
consider the positive impacts
also for development such as
this.
And the positive impact that it
could have to our fisheries and
the positive impact that it can
just have to the quality of our
life in general.
Thank you no thank you so much
as common in your apps the right
your spot on I in regards ocean
acidification and how
challenging it's been -- And
it's getting worse -- Because of
our reliance on fossil fuels so
I'm grateful that you made that
point today as well.
Thank you so much.
Good afternoon good afternoon
senator requires could destroy
us all can Bates humble
fisherman's marketing
association -- My job has been
representing fishermen.
Or with land use and zoning and
planning person spot in.
Nineteen eighty two on I am a
couple things to say some of the
things that no and person
touched on when you talk about
the regulations in the matter
closed areas in California it's
tremendous.
The former ticket to to to take
a felt pen.
And start blacking in the areas
off the California coast weather
is restricted areas are closures
most of the coast close to Scott
some sort of encumbrance on it.
So when when nor talks about
basically compete in an eminent
domain essentially these fishing
areas this is something that
fishermen are so extremely
conservative and considered.
The word about there's really no
place to go.
By the same token fishermen
understand that these projects
have to go forward so.
The trick is to try to find a
balance home office Sherman's
marketing association has about
a year's worth of dialogue with.
A principal power in with our
local energy provider through
Matthew Marshall here.
And we're so we're slowly moving
along there's a lot to lots of
work to do.
On the second thing that I'd
like to touch on is that a lot
of people think that these
impacts to the fishing fleet.
Be it displacement in the ocean
or displacement on should always
far shore side facilities or
something that's going to happen
in the far distant future.
And that is actually not correct
--
It starts immediately with
planning and essentially for for
humble Bates it started on the
particular date all of the
humble bay harbor district put
in a request. For a grant to go
ahead and look at redesigning
redwood terminal number one
which is a facility that's 20%
occupied by the fishing fleet.
So these things have to be
planned for way ahead of time.
Again the trick is fishermen all
these things are coming and to
try to minimize the mounting
impacts to this industry so that
we can survive.
Through this and the entire
state to prosper thank you.
It's Bates thank you so much and
thank you for your on going
after exam behalf the fleet.
Yeah I would like to be a
welcome the supervisor at to the
hearing thank you so much better
supervisor before about this
thank you very much senator I'm
just here to say.
A huge thank you to you because
being on the a redwood coast
energy authority -- Representing
the county of humble -- We have
a C. C. E. O. commute --
Community choice -- G. -- Which
dedicated itself -- To providing
1100% clean power by twenty
twenty five not twenty forty
five three so we're talking
about local clean energy but
also just the concept of
everybody talking together.
Is extremely important and there
were a couple of things
mentioned I'm also on the
advisory committee -- For born
so I'm very well aware of the
project the process they're
going through as well but I
would like to say that there
were a few things were said that
really struck me -- Jennifer
said doing the right thing the
right way.
Because we're we're going in the
right direction and all of the
screener G. also protecting the
environment protection the
fisheries so we've got a
wonderful wonderful task ahead
of us.
The challenge is great but it's
very very exciting so I really
hope we we continue with these.
Nine anything you put together
I'm right there Anderson -- Also
I think the idea of offshore
wind and and I'm a great fan of
these guys that are doing this
clean energy have been following
them in Europe central.
But the idea that they are the
new stake holders I think was a
a really good one mentioned by
and because when a lot of times.
Something is going forward it's
got a lot of energy it's a big
movement and you say we need to
include the stake holders -- And
it's kind of like Wilk who were
at the stake holders well.
There to stake holders in our
environment and we need to
include them but we also need to
work very closely together so I
just want to say a very big
thank you to you.
I put myself to working as hard
as I can to make sure this works
no I appreciate that ma'am
supervisor and you have been in
yeah I know your name continue
to as well appreciate your
advocacy.
Thank you for being here for the
entire time as well -- We're
grateful for your testimony
today we like to be able to
announce our last call for
public testimony.
Last call for public testimony.
Or anyone else would like to be
able to address the committee
this time.
All right here in C. nine would
like to be able to bring it back
to committee and to be able to
have a few closing comments.
There's some thank you said we'd
like to be able to advance and
then -- Closing comments first
of all want to say thank you to
all of you who have been with
us.
Since this morning and we are so
grateful for your testimony
today we're grateful for your
feedback and just know.
This is just the beginning just
the beginning of this process or
we want to be able to formalize
as we move forward with both the
state agencies as well as the
federal agencies.
We want to say -- Send a hearty
thank you to each of the
panelists.
Who have traveled from far and
wide to be able to be here today
I think Wiener giver panels
another round of applause for
these?
There's some folks who helped
put together this hearing -- And
we wouldn't be here without them
today again the individual to my
right in in particular -- We owe
a debt of gratitude to as always
that's Mister Tom west Nile the
chief consultant countries.
That Tom.
Want to say thank you to Carly
revisions well stated Marcin and
also Thomas with soul who is the
district representative for
humble Trinity as well don't
tell our counties. For all their
work we would not be able to do
without them we want to say
thank you to both Dana and Phil
were behind the camera -- In if
you heard any cussing that was
probably Dana with the camera so
--
I do want to say thank you so
much we want to say thank you to
Jeremiah and the Roy who are the
Senate sergeants were here today
for all their work.
Find the ladies and gentlemen I
want to leave with a few words.
Number one is early number two
is often we need to be
communicating early about this
issue we need to be
communicating often about
offshore wind energy.
It we need to get together as a
group get in front of this to be
able to formalize the process.
And I'd like to be able to end
it as I started.
We need to expedite the work of
the task force that was created
by both the federal and state
governments to put meat on the
bone.
Meat on the bone when it comes
to the rules and regulations to
protect fishing grounds and our
coastal environment where
turbines would be located.
As we know as we heard in many
cases turbines would be placed
at where there are high winds
which also could coincide with
up weld waters.
In these waters have high levels
of nutrients which mean there
are high levels of foods or
foods from sources which means
our robust fisheries and marine
life in the same locations or
potential turbines would be
located.
There are several follow ups
including learning from -- What
is happened in the past so that
we do not repeat those mistakes
in the future -- And also
learning what has worked in the
past so we can replicate those
issues in the future here on the
north coast.
This is not going to be the last
time this is just the first that
we're gonna be coming together
and we promise you here in the
next twelve months will be
having a follow up hearing -- Is
we start working with the
regulatory agencies the fireman
organizations.
Out labor.
This is Wells industry to be a
start at putting details and
firming up the vision of what
this will look like here on the
north coast.
On behalf of the entire
committee thank you for joining
us -- In if you are in the wind
you may also be Andy cannabis.
I and we invite you to our one
stop shop grand opening at four
o'clock today -- Where we're
going to be opening up -- The
first of its kind at one stop
service center that will have
five different state agencies
all under one roof serving the
north coast I just three million
dollar investment by the city
California.
The ribbon cutting is at four
o'clock and we hope that you'll
be able to join us so we make a
licensing and permitting --
Easier here on the north coast
--
Is well four o'clock -- There --
Right it was a time standard is
time standard is on the top
floor city California will now
be on the bottom floor there in
downtown Eureka without further
ado.
Thank you so much we are
adjourned